all right uh good morning welcome
to the subcommittee we are discussing
three bills i was going to go through
the easiest one first what i think is
the easiest one hb 1330.
um
and have an amendment this has got to do
with medical technicians and
let me get my notes
so during the hearing what we discovered
or what i remember is that we are the
only state that tried to license medical
technicians and those people cannot
really do any work
uh outside a hospital so they need to
get access to the hospital to the
rooms the x-ray rooms and things like
that
and they are always supervised by the
doctors
so there is really little point in
trying to license them
um and um we had a conversation at the
end of the testimony with the oplc
director
and
um
bill marshall is a doctor champion and
it was pretty much in agreement that
this whole chapter needs to go
and that's what my amendment is about
so
any
comments questions
representative golly
thank you mr chair i
just have some
concerns of
getting rid of this board all together
and the registering of medical tax
i know while this may be germaine it's
totally different than what the bill was
doing and making them advisory only
and i just have an issue with not
holding a hearing on
take getting rid of them all together
having it done it's i just
don't think that's what was posted it
was noticed that was in the bill and
this is
well it entails the same subject it is
doing something totally different than
what the bill did and i just can't
support this at that
support this amendment at this time
oh thank you
i think it'll be up to the chair
to determine whether it's germain or not
so
thank you yeah please
i understand that and it probably could
be
raised as jermaine but i just think that
this was not what was the intent of the
legislation and
goes about it in a totally different
direction thank you
any yeah
any more input but
that's that's what i would like to do i
think this is straightforward um
well
we'll be up to the full to committee
after this
so oh sure sure i think yeah thank you
make a motion to adopt the amendment
i'll second it
um
any discussion
let me speak about you first and second
less is more
all right
yeah i mean uh it seems like this is
what was supported by other members of
the committee and
uh oplc
thank you
any more discussion
i think i've
raised my concerns and that's the only
concern i have about this thank you
thank you thank you
please call the rule
representative santana stasso
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative goalie
no
uh representative fellows not here
uh represent uh the chair
yes okay
so that would be three uh three to one
okay
all right
so
closing that one moving on to
uh the next easy one 1497. are you going
to do the vote as with amendment i'll
have to pass with them oh yes yes of
course
thank you
motion to uh uh ought to pass uh the
bill with a as amended with amendment
seconded
all right no
discussion no comments yeah thank you
yep please
representative samson estasso yes
the clerk quotes yes representative
goalie
no
fellows
on the chair yes please
three to one
thank you so 1497
um
very simple change one line change they
can there was a concern that something
got accidentally deleted from the deal
from the bill
and um
does anyone in the public wants to
clarify i 1a 2a anybody
oh all right please
please introduce yourself
1497 yes
please introduce yourself thank you mr
chairman um on 1497 the concern we had
was a member joining the retirement
system or any member that would leave
out that the people that are currently
employed so we would have to be current
members and
members upon joining the retirement
system and any member who reaches this
uh service age so you gotta you gotta
include the current employees also which
is not included in this language
so what would you propose the exact
sentence to be the beginning of the
sentence please
any current employ any current member
or members upon joining the retirement
system any member who has reached
service age
any current member or members
okay unicorn okay
okay thank you thank you
mr carlin yes
maybe the microphone
thank you yeah and i do have an
additional uh comment on mr beaudry's
suggestion as well but to get back to
your original question yeah striking out
uh 100 a5 1a and 2a
could open up the benefit to folks who
were eligible for early service
retirement but not yet sir full-service
retirement because they're both
contained in different sections of a5 so
restoring that would
basically keep the benefit available to
the same pool of people it is now but
just allow you know members prior to
service retirement to elect it
and then um just for
for brevity uh perhaps on on the first
comment and i know representative
pearson brought this up at the public
hearing the point upon joining the
retirement system
could be seen to exclude people who are
already in the system so if that just
said any active member comma any member
who has reached service retirement age
etc you know then then if you're working
you can you could
put in for this
okay
all right uh thank you so
if you couldn't send me that exact
language please just email it
and i'll get it drafted hopefully we
pass it today sure thing thank you
so
so current or active um
pick one please
yeah and just the verb is a better
statutory term active definition of
active memory okay
okay yeah if you could please send it to
me and then
i think
right
oh please representative goalie
thank you mr chair and also can we
also
so that we have it in two places in case
something doesn't go through
when we do the amendment
could you please clarify
house bill 1557
is
pertains to the same
portion of the statute right right so if
we could have that language included in
the amendment we have drafted on 1497 to
make sure it's in both bills because if
one passes before the other it's going
to revert back to
yeah i'm not familiar with that bill
that much
was there a subcommittee for that one or
where is that what's the status of 1557.
that was exactly the past so that's why
i want to make sure it's in both bills
because that's already agreed upon
language with this committee
oh okay
so all right so we'll get the front of
the sentence from mr carlin and then the
tale of it will be right there from the
bill 1557 right correct okay thank you
thank you thank you
okay thank you
the change is from any member to or any
active member
pretty much yeah and bringing back the
1a into a
that got deleted
thank you
um
okay yeah if mr carlin please send me
the
verbiage
and i'll include the 1557 language in
i don't think we need to vote
not until we have the amendment okay
nothing formal
and i don't think we need a subcommittee
anymore we'll just draft it and bring it
to the full committee
okay
um
that's it
so i think we're done with 14.97 thank
you
so the next one is
1587.
um so the handout this handout
we just received would you like to
explain it please
to us again yeah thank you mr chairman
um i don't know if you want for the
record i'm off the boudry representing
the new hampshire state permanent
firefighters retirement association
i handed out
a
worksheet this is what i i spoke about
when i testified on on the bill at the
hearing
but if you look uh at the page with um
where it says based on highest five
years
the first column is prior to july first
which is the old
language so uh column a that firefighter
worked no overtime um
firefighter b
that that firefighter worked overtime in
their last five years
so fire
firefighter a would get a twenty
thousand dollar pension
because that was that's their average
final earnings
firefighter b
their average final earnings would have
been twenty five thousand dollars so
they would get a pension of twenty five
thousand dollars
then you go to um
the current language that's in the law
right now
same thing firefighter a works no
overtime firefighter b the last five
years
they work they work some overtime
but if you look at it um under the
current language they still would only
get twenty thousand dollars even though
firefighter b
for five years put in twenty five
thousand dollars in contributions they
would they would not get credit for that
so the language that's in the in house
bill um 14
uh
would be uh the proposed changes so
firefighter a again works no overtime at
all
gets twenty thousand dollar pension
firefighter b
would work their last five years they
would they would work some overtime so
when you average out their career
they would end up with twenty one
thousand dollars so they would get
credit for those last five years it's
not as substantial as
uh the old system where they would get
uh credit for the last five years and
not average out their their full
years of service but at least they're
getting credit for the money that they
put into the retirement system and paid
on
and that that's that's that's the
difference they're actually um
getting credit for what they paid for
thank you any questions yeah
representative golly
thank you and i just want to be clear
that
they're paying into the system
working those years right now currently
but not receiving credit for it correct
that would be that would be the middle
the middle case and that's under current
law they would pay they've been paying
in the system but they don't get credit
for those years
thank you
thank you thank you
oh yes please representative fellows
what do you mean the depth
yes
maybe the microphone yeah steps
to do that calculation
how do well
we try to make it it's simple that's why
we went with 25 years um so the first
the first 20 years
they they earned 20 000 their last five
years because they worked overtime they
might have got promoted and
and um work worked overtime they they
were they were averaging 25 000 a year
for those last five years
under the current law those five years
don't count no that part i understand
the proposal so
the proposal says
um
the percent that's in it says refers to
the percentage average percentage
of compensation
that's the excess right
so
because if you take 25 years and you
average all those numbers out it comes
out to 21 000 a year
so those five years
boost that average by 20 percent because
you're taking your last five years that
are not included right now and now
you're going to put them into your
calculation of your
full years of service which would add a
roughly under these scenario 20 percent
into your calculations which brings you
to 21 000 a year
well am i making myself clear no no
because
so their excess is 5 000.
their base is 20 yep and their excess is
25.
their excess is five correct so that is
25 percent
no because you've got to average it over
the 25 years you you got to average all
those numbers out over the 25 years
so
so if you if you had a calculator and
you averaged all those numbers and then
multiplied it by uh divided it by 25
you're going to come up with 21 000.
oh because it shall not exceed
right so if they were getting 25 000 the
whole time
then they would okay
so so it's so it's um
the average
still says average right average over
their lifetime over their career okay
so every one two ten two so 25 000
excess
right but divided by 25 years divided by
okay yeah
okay now i understand that you pretty
much have to add it all up and divide it
by the 25 years
because that's what that's what the law
says you um you your average of all your
years of service but under the current
law it says excluding your last five
years so what we're doing is we're
adding like your last five years in the
calculation
well it does it says
service
on or after
2012. so we're only talking about
10 10 years
this year and 11 years
next year
yeah but there's some there was there's
there's firefighters out there that if
they had if they were invested they were
they were part of the system so you
could have you could have nine years on
the job you're going to be underneath
this so you're nine and you got 11 years
you saw you you're almost 20 years of
service
so these people are coming close to
starting to retire now
okay
so for the first ones
it's only going to be like for the ones
retiring this year it's just going to be
over it's not going to be their whole
time it's going to be over the last 10
11 years and but then it works its way
up
right i would have to see with it data
service and i can't i couldn't answer
that okay
thank you
thank
you um
i don't know mr carlin if you have any
more if you have any insights on
on this chart as well
or the yeah
charger
okay
over your base um
and how that is average because right
now there's two separate calculations
high size and everything else and then
the lower percentage is applied this
bill would
be high five versus entire career you
know so
you know as
indicated in this chart it increases the
pension by some degree but not
completely
depending on how the person's salary
so
yeah so the 20 right there yeah maybe
you want to step to the microphone
so the 20
um at the bottom of the chart if you
have a copy of it
right there a percent of our time to be
used for afc is 20
the 20
comes from where exactly okay so in in
again in this chart um you know the the
base was 20 and um
25 000 was the total so there was 5 000
was compensation over base in those last
five years twenty percent yeah yeah and
actually with twenty
five five thousand
twenty five percent in two thousand
twenty thousand but you know same
principle basically the current formula
will take the lower of the two
percentages which is zero for the rest
of this hypothetical career so they
wouldn't recognize they wouldn't
recognize any of that compensation over
base in their average final compensation
but when you average
those five years with the other 20
um you know it does it does actually you
know add a thousand dollars to the uh to
the final compensation which is a piece
of the pension formula
so
um so that that's how that works it's
it's
the exclusion of the high five from the
rest of the career is is what the
current law does now and this bill would
um use use the high five in both sides
of that equation
and and just to a question earlier about
prior to um
january 1st of 12
compensation was reported as one line
item to the retirement system so it's
all typic technically considered base so
if somebody has years before
um or months before one one of 12
that isn't included in the career
calculation of comp over base because we
don't have the data
okay
all right
and
any any more questions yeah
representative golly
so
marty under the
current
current statutes
we heard that
those folks whether it's in corrections
police fire
that we see are short-staffed and people
are forced to work the overtime
in their last years of service
and those hours that they're working
are not counting towards the system
correct
towards their retirement
calculations you can't make a blanket
statement to that effect because it
depends on how much
comp over base they're earning in their
high five versus their other years if
they're earning more in their final they
end up what ended up being their high uh
earning less
in their their high five because their
base salary is up you know all of it
would be recognized so it really
it depends on the the salary pattern of
the individual um some people absolutely
it's gonna lower their afc some people
it could be neutral you know if the
percentage is
lower in the high five already then none
of the money in the high five is is
reduced
but there are scenarios where this isn't
counting towards every time towards
their final
a portion of the the uh compensation and
the high five is not counting towards
the pension calculation in some cases
yeah it could
and one last question
and there is
a cap as the
the individual can't make unlimited
overtime and build up their
pension just by working
overtime
you know 200 percent above doubling
their pay for the year to count that
towards their retirement there's a cap
as to how much they can there there is a
it's it's been in the books for about 30
years now there's a cap on the last year
of earnable compensation so when
somebody's final year you know they they
couldn't work you know 20 hours a day
and you know make the cap is anything
over 150
of uh the next highest year in the afc
we can't count towards the pension
thank you representative phillips
um
what we're talking about here today does
that have is that um
let me
turn this around
so
state workers for example
get to cash in sick days and
vacation days
do those are those days that pay part of
the calculation
in here no no because
the um using uh or taking payouts of
accrued leave time sick time vacation
etc
is no longer earnable compensation for
anyone who was invested prior to january
1st of 2012. they'd still obviously get
the money from the state or from the
employer if it's if it's part of an
agreement but the legislature excluded
those pay types you know unused
leave time
from earnable compensation so the people
who are affected by
1587 it already doesn't count for them
so it doesn't play into this at all
it's only that those pay types are only
for vested members
in terms of the pension the follow-up
um well it's actually another question
okay please so
if i when i look at the the the changes
that are proposed here is an amendment
i'm wondering if instead of writing a
new separate paragraph down here c
and and
could what if we just
edited line 18 and 19 and just took the
excluded
excluding the highest five off and it
would apply to group one and group two
would we would we get the same result
for group two
um
if if you're if you're not going to vote
on it right away my initial analysis is
yes um but i i would want to you know
just vet that you know with a couple of
folks at the office i think c was added
so there's a distinction between group
one and group two
in this bill so and then you know this
this bill only does apply to group two
members as as written so there's you
know this this you know the group one
population still has that
five year versus the rest of the career
um
so i i
initial analysis yes and i can you know
if the committee's interested i could
get you an answer today
follow up
well it's not a question but
but my thought is that
i don't know i don't see why we should
be doing this only for group two and not
group one
i don't i don't understand any
justification for doing it differently
for the two groups
it would cost
i don't i don't know if it would cost
i'm not sure it would cost very much
more because i think that this the issue
of having all this extra time over time
um is
a lot way way less prevalent in group
one than in group two
yeah i couldn't venture a guess on that
i i just just i mean teachers tend to
work on a contract salary so there is
not much if any comp over base that may
be a coaching site end or something some
employees depending like you know
first thing comes to mind is highway
folks may have more overtime
opportunities than you know an office
worker but you know it's uh it's a
larger cohort of the membership but
the availability of overtime and
differentials and things like that is
probably less on average
i yeah i'd rather not complicate the
bill that's complex enough already um
please represent the fellows well i i
think that
it may the bill may look more complicate
you know i mean we could
obviously just vote to pass this the way
it's written
but in the long run
somebody's just going to say next year
like why are we treating them
differently and that the fact that
you've made you know two you know you've
got a distinction between two different
groups when you don't really need to do
that
makes makes the
resulting legislation more complicated
thank you thank you yeah
yeah representative golly
thank you mr chair
i look at it right now as an issue of
recruitment and retention especially of
group two members we're hearing with
police fire and
our public safety individuals and
corrections
we're looking at
the
easiest way
without having to
break the bank of doing this i think if
you
add everyone in all at once
and you see the cost and marty i may be
wrong here but i think the cost when you
add in all of group one would actually
add a substantial amount of money to
what this fiscal note is currently
um
that
the sponsors are trying to
do it in a way that
the state can afford
and make some progress toward towards
restoring a benefit
and
that's why i believe this was brought
forward and the sponsors here he may
want to
oh yes please if you want to step up to
the microphone
exactly has said um
please just kevin i'm kevin
representative kevin pratt uh retired
fire chief um fighter fighter 42 years
and also five years with sieber nuclear
power plant senior fire brigade leader
so i have private
service and i have municipal service so
i can see both sides of that
this is basically written to restore a
benefit that was already there
we thought for many years that it was
changed to the three highest years and
thanks to the five highest years
but with this one line at the end it
basically excludes the five highest
years and really substantially changes
and makes it unfair for people that work
or get promoted in their last five
highest years
it doesn't have to be the last years but
it's the highest five years so
it's not necessarily the last five years
but it could be most likely is if they
get a promotion
uh it would be in the last five years
but it doesn't have to be it's just the
highest five years so so it's not fair
for
some employees to work and not get
recognized for the money they put in for
their retirement it's like 11 almost 12
now so they're paying like 12 on five
years of work that they're not getting
recognized for
so we wanted to straighten that out and
that that puts it back more in line with
the way it was for this group too
group one may want to consider their own
bill in that same idea
but the number of people that are in
group two compare the number of people
in group one would be substantially
different in price
there are more teachers in manchester
than there are than all the firefighters
in the state of new hampshire
so the number of people that would be
included in this would be substantially
increased if you did that
any other questions um
i had a question just
writing things down
no no thank you
yeah i forgot so we're just trying to
clarify it make it as
simple as possible in one paragraph as
opposed to making it more complicated
and uh
and also make it fair for the people
that are putting into the system
basically it's a fairness issue thank
you any questions from the committee
and let me just touch on the recruitment
and retention please yeah that that is
very very true and uh it's very true not
only in the full-time union fire
departments and police departments but
it trickles down into the call
and volunteer fire department ranks
many many people have started in the
volunteer and call ranks
and worked their way up to become a
full-time person
and
now it's not as desirable to do that
with these massive changes that took
place uh ten years ago
uh so now you're seeing and with the
other things that are happening in the
country uh policemen and
and firemen jobs are not being uh
flooded with people anymore
i was also 18 years uh fire stands and
training commissioner
and we saw the numbers of people taking
the test dwindled down from hundreds and
hundreds like 300 at one point down to
like 50 people
and the 50 people that pay to take the
test don't even show up half of them
don't even show up
so
it's getting scary in the near future
and what's going to happen is when this
fi this here goes into effect
people that never understood this was
going to happen and i've been following
the system very closely and i didn't
realize it was a five-year exclusion
on the highest five years you're
basically going to calculate your
retirement on year six seven eight nine
and ten which are very low compared to
the last five years or the highest five
years
so what's going to happen is everybody's
going to wake up you know and they're in
the system now and the people looking to
come into the system and they're going
to go wow i can make so much more money
in the private industry i took a ten
thousand dollar pay cut to come from the
nuclear industry to the fire service as
fire chief and that was one of the
highest paid positions you could get and
i took a ten thousand dollar pay cut
when i retired it was twenty thousand
dollars more i could have made if i
stayed there a year
so um so people are going to start to
stay in the in uh in the private sector
they're going to do all kinds of other
jobs
and they may not even be in the fire
service so
this is going to have long term
terrible effects for retention and
recovery of people and retention of
people
and i could go on all day but i won't
thank you
any questions
so so the fact that this was done i
think that was somewhat advertised by
the retirement system i saw some
documentation from 2011 where this was
described but somehow many people don't
pay attention to those is that the
problem uh the retirement system does a
very good job about sending people out
anybody that wants to have somebody come
to and they did it in rockingham county
they'd bring it out to their county
buildings and different places to
educate people and it was said over and
over again
instead of your top three years it's
going to be your top five years
is what they're going to base it on and
everybody said well that'll be a little
bit worse because it's going to include
two years at a lower
but that isn't what happened it actually
ended up being excluded your five
highest years and that's not the way it
was educated to people and for many
years everybody did not know that it
wasn't going to be your five highest
years we're going to be excluded totally
so you're paying into the system
for five years that you get no credit
for and that's just plain not fair
okay thank you
yep
oh question
uh just uh just a comment if i may
please
because
we keep hearing we're restoring a
benefit
but it's not fully restoring a benefit
if you look at the numbers
uh from art beaudry's that he has in
front of us
that prior to 2011
you'd be making the 25 000 upon
retirement and
with this bill you're making 21 000 so
it's not fully restoring a benefit so we
need to just remember that that we're
partially restoring a benefit that was
that's hard that's a good point i kind
of misspoke there there were seven
things done 10 years ago that changed
the system forever this is only one of
those seven things
so you're only restoring one little
piece of it and this piece here is uh a
fairness issue if you look at the other
six things you could you could discuss
whether it's fair or not but this one
here is definitely a fairness issue you
shouldn't be paying into a system that
you don't get credit for
yeah okay thank you
and i uh to recall i think this is
coming out of the general fund
right
no okay
would you like to speak
oh yes please yes
good morning mr chair good morning good
morning
michael gear i'm the new hampshire
police association president
i just want to reiterate what everyone
had mentioned the retention and
recruitment
it's a tough subject it's not a secret
every police department in the state is
short
on staff
and i think
this bill will help in
retaining people
one
two this is a subject where everyone is
talking about in the state of new
hampshire every law enforcement
firefighters
uh we're all talking about this subject
and i think
restoring or
put it back the way it was before it's
going to help every department in the
long run
okay thank you any questions
representative golly
and when you talk about that
wouldn't that also lead to if you could
read
recruitment and retention especially the
retention portion of it
save municipalities money and not having
to continually recruit and train
individuals correct because it does cost
a lot of money every time a police
officer
leaves the department you'll have to
replace that police officer and there's
a lot of money that you have to spend
again over and over again it's costing
municipalities a lot of money to just to
get that person started and out on the
road
thank you
as well as over time for the unfilled
positions correct
thank you thank you
question thank you
all right
any more discussion
any ideas
anything
yes please miss representative goli
if there's
no further discussion i would make a
motion mr
chair oh any discussion
all right
no discussion all right
oh please
yeah
i'm not going to support this
just a couple of things the idea that um
they're having problems with recruiting
and retention because the retirement
system doesn't count the last five years
i just don't think it follows because uh
recruiting retention is a global problem
right now there's no nobody can keep
anybody uh
even in the private sector they're
throwing all sorts of benefits and
bonuses at people and people are moving
on i think it's a 20th century mentality
that somebody stays and works for
one place
for a whole career
um and i just think that we're moving
away from that
um
and then
i just i wasn't actually surprised
when i learned about the retirement
system that you know it failed its
contributors being a government
retirement system
but to dip into the general fund and
rope in additional victims
to the retirement system uh
that
won't that are contribute that will now
be contributing to it but getting
nothing back i don't think that uh two
wrongs make a right kind of thing and
these are the reasons i'm not going to
support it
thank you
representative goalie
thank you mr chair i do have to respond
because
recruitment and retention goes well
before
the situation we're in today when this
bill was passed in
these changes which took place in 2011
2012 well before this economy is where
it's at today and having an issue with
businesses recruiting and retaining
employees
the fire service the police department's
corrections all started seeing a
dramatic change in recruitment and
retention just due to the changes that
were made in the system so it shows if
you go back and you look at the
municipalities that it wasn't because of
the economy we were in it was because of
the changes that we made
and when i go back and look at using
general fund money
the state used to put in 35 percent of
the cost to municipalities
and no longer contributes
so i i think we we had a precedence they
are setting
that the state did pay for a portion of
the retirement funding for
municipalities and uh
this would just be a small amount
versus what they had
contributed
in the years past
thank you
all right um
then
all right yeah
if
i guess representative golly
if no more discussion please state your
motion move forward to pass on house
bill 1587.
and i think i've
said enough maybe a second
okay second
yes please speak to emotion and i think
i've said enough reasons why we should
be doing this um you know let's just
remember that we're not fully restoring
a benefit when you look at the numbers
but we are
at least
adding those years in that the
individuals are paying into the
retirement system taking having money
taken out of their paychecks for a
benefit they're not receiving during
those years
thank you
would you like to speak to a second
so i i support this bill
because it does fix
a problem
well it goes it at least it goes it at
least it
makes a problem
not quite as bad as it is right now
i i am concerned that
planning and changes related to the
retirement system
that come before the legislature we see
them every year and it's like just we're
doing piecemeal
patches
and i just think that
it would be better
to do some
forward thinking and try to address all
the issues
more comprehensively but
since this does make
this since this puts a band-aid on it i
support this bill
thank you
um
if no more discussion yes please mr
clerk
uh representative sent an estasso on otp
on 1587.
no
the clerk votes no
representative goalie
yes
representative fellows yes
and the chair
yes
so that's three to two it passes
thank you
i think we're done
with the subcommittee sorry i dragged
everybody out does this go to um this
goes to finance right does it go
anywhere else it needs to come back to
the full committee first well yes but
yes it will i think yes it should go to
finance
now
just a little bookkeeping these forms
record the count but not who
do you want the who also
uh
who you said yes yeah yes first and
second place but there's no place for
that on the farm oh okay
so i think we're done thank
i you expecting a longer discussion
sorry dragged everybody out so early
thank you
yes
oh
a little bit of what they put into the
city
oh
and if you look at
you're getting a thousand dollars and
you're putting in 25 grand
that's right
thanks buddy
thank you
so there's
uh
um
individual
you know
haven't had a chance
okay
hmm
um
is
right that makes sense
okay
eliminated
yeah like i said i'll uh
is
i've told our committee researcher you
do something three-hole punch it because
everybody asks them anything about
printed have a
give me a break if there's nobody up
there
you know come on
it's just not january
if anybody's got a filled out pink card
they can bring it forward
you're uh you're here
your name is upside down
thanks
if you're trying to frame a
sometimes
good morning
i have a couple of announcements first
the
there are in our office a supply of
copies of the
retirement system annual report
i also have one set of all the kaffirs
for the state the liquor commission and
a couple of others anyone who's
interested is more than welcome to
borrow and read them
you might even keep them as far as i'm
concerned
but they are available for your
appraisal
and
a reminder
we will be executing on monday if you're
not going to be be here you let me know
so you're you've got a con okay i'll get
a replacement no trouble
okay
uh anyone else again let me know
so
i'll open the hearing on house bill
1357.
and
i don't see any of the sponsors
representative schmidt is your since
you're passing by would you care to
introduce this
good morning everyone uh madam chair
thank you
uh i'm
introducing house bill 1357
relative to land acknowledgement which i
uh happen to be fully in support of
um
and
let me just pull out the right sheet
here
this is
sponsored by representative cushing and
it's got a boatload of
distinguished people supporting it
and i see a couple of
my indigenous friends who are here this
morning
and they will be happy to
speak to this issue
but as i say i think it's a good idea so
i'll take no questions thank
you thank you representative schmidt
mr and mrs fulot
ourselves first
kwai needle bach and dilla was in denise
julio sagamo wade ella was in paul
poglio sagamo kawasaki bandwidth
it would be helpful if you were not in a
mask
i'm sorry um the indigenous population
has a twenty percent survival rate at
catching covid
i'm okay with that
that's fine you just have to let me know
i can adjust accordingly
quinn needlebach in delaware denise
julio
alton new hampshire hello friends my
name is denise puglio and this is paul
puglio we're the head speakers of the
kawasaki band at the pentacles abner
people located in alton new hampshire
we're here today to speak on behalf of
hb 1357
an act relative to a land acknowledgment
here in new hampshire
one of the handouts we have given you
was uh from the
native american indian commission the
commissioner herself is uh
not feeling well so she couldn't be in
attendance today so one of those
handouts has to come right from the
new hampshire
[Music]
ann jenison the chair of the native
american
commission
our band has been working
with communities
businesses and organizations
throughout new england that are
acknowledging the
the prior history of land use by
indigenous people by
making statements of
recognizing the land was once indigenous
land and it's now being stewarded
by uh other people colonial people that
have that have taken over our lands
uh
most notable are some of the bigger
institutions like
the korea art museum which uh has now
put in foia a statement similar to this
many of the churches within
the new hampshire area have already
adopted similar land stewardship
statements recognizing that
that indigenous people cannot maintain
this land as they once did and
that they are now stewards of our land
this goes back historically to george
washington
washington recognized that
during the all of the turmoil of indian
wars in new england and the northeast
that the lands were pretty much taken
from indigenous people
so when the constitution and the
declaration of independence were written
in 1790 george washington uh signed off
on a uh
a non-intercourse act or intercourse act
as it was written back then
it was one of the first
acts done by our congress that
recognized that only congress should be
handling the affairs of dealing with
land acquisition sale and bartering and
trade with indigenous communities
if you read some of washington's deep
diaries in history you'll find that he
had a deep love and admiration for
indigenous people in particular the
abnegay which we have copies of letters
from
from washington acknowledging our
support of the colonial efforts in the
1776 time period
uh there was also another treaty that
was in an act called the j act which was
done in 1794 which impacted us in
northeast because it established the
right to cross the border to and from
canada for indigenous groups back in
that time period
so what we're doing here is we're asking
that you to put this historical footnote
and that's all it is really that this
land was once
occupied by our uh our ancestors
and uh in particular the penacook right
here in new hampshire right here in
concord and all this does is it adds a
like a historical footnote in the
preamble and it uh it ties in with the
boundaries and the meats and bounds that
were established
between all the states the geopolitical
and uh
of our influences so all we're doing is
asking for this to be added as a
historical footnote in the uh
in the appropriate place in our state
documents
we uh
we did note one thing and it's it's no
fault of anybody but we noted that
spell check spell check spell checking
of our language is very difficult and
the second page just explains the fact
that a couple of the words were not
uh they were phonetically spelled out
but not in our language properly so we
give you the second page showing the two
words that don't make sense
because our language is very complicated
the flora represents our terms of saying
we have a great forest here because
we're forest people and hunter-gatherers
and the fauna we're referring to are the
wild animals of our of our state which
were so important to us as a people back
in those days so
the use of the language was
requested of us in several locations
the university of new hampshire had
worked very deeply with us to try to
come up with a land acknowledgement
because they recognized that the
university of new hampshire was a
land-grant
college
if there's uh
if there's any other questions it's this
is really not a
a very debatable thing it's just a
matter where it would be accepted as a
statement
it's consistent with what a lot of the
churches museums and other institutions
and schools have been doing by bringing
into their preambles that this was once
indigenous land and is now being
stewarded by other people
and we are grateful to that because
we are but little and small and small
percentage of our population is uh still
remaining but we still like to think of
this homeland as ours being protected
and stewarded by by the great state of
new hampshire
and any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
are there questions from the committee
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you
representative horrigan
thank you very much madam chairs i'm
representing timothy horrigan from
um stratfor county district six which is
the towns of durham and and madbury
and um
so yes as uh as you already know it
honors the pentagon ebenaki and wabanaki
people still are the
who were and really still are the
original stewards of the land variously
known as antikina and new hampshire
and the peoples of our state regardless
of
what how long ago we came here or why
we're all dependent on the land
the floor and the fauna for you know
everything we need to survive you know
throughout the land and as resources and
i forgot this in the water but without
without the resources of our land we're
all uh you know we're all pretty uh
we're all totally helpless much as we um
and it's appropriate being heard the
first day of black history month since
this bill shows the history isn't just
it's not just the white people's history
that uh there's uh
people of all colors here in new
hampshire
and it's also appropriate being heard
i guess i i'm i'm probably
reasonably loud but i'm kind of my mask
is kind of scraping against the
microphone so i'll uh take the mask off
for the brief period it takes me to
speak which hopefully be about one more
minute so it's appropriate
well we're dealing with the pandemic
political unrest because
the land now known as england was
originally settled or more actually
stolen them
and i'm
some of my ancestors were part of that
during a time of pandemic and unrest so
when the people we know in the history
books as the pilgrims arrived in what is
now known as massachusetts
they encountered a beautiful well-tended
unpopulated land with fields and forests
which seemed to be perfect for their
colonies needs and
they also found a number of mounds where
corn and beans were conveniently buried
and um they
assumed that god had left them there but
that's not what happened the land merely
appeared to be unpopulated the abenaki
people were decimated by a plague um
it's probably smallpox but we're not
sure
and uh which also led to war and civil
unrest um
and those uh conveniently located
mountains were were
were graves and they were left there not
by god for you know the pilgrims benefit
but um you know as a tribute to the
dead who were buried in the mounds so um
that's uh
and actually
they founded the town of plymouth
massachusetts where plymouth rock is was
uh also a uh
also an indigenous uh village named
patuxes so it's even and they celebrated
their 400th anniversary ironically
during the year of the pandemic in 1620
so
this bill is very timely and um
i think if it's very appropriate it goes
in rsa one colon one right at the
beginning of the law book since you know
as i said the the land and its resources
and the people are the basis of you know
everything else that the law books deal
with all
you know over 600 volumes of it now so
that's um that's why this uh so that's
why i support this bill and i urge you
to find it ought to pass and also
just mention a little thing
it takes existing rsa one colon one
about parametering the boundaries and it
makes it one
dash a which is a simple change i did
notice we don't parameter boundaries
with the province of quebec which uh i
thought was that was interesting but of
course it is
part of a different
different countries so maybe that's why
it is so
thanks
thank you representative horrigan are
there any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you all right thank
you
janet perkins
houlard
hi good morning my name is janet perkins
holland and i reside in durham new
hampshire i'm a member of the indigenous
new hampshire collaborative
and the human rights commission in
durham
which has recently adopted a land
acknowledgment based on
the one that is has been adopted at unh
i um in in favor of this bill be as i
think it would be valuable as more than
just uh symbolic
i have been incredibly fortunate
and had the advantage of living in
durham for the past 24 years and
have um it's
no more
evident to me over the past two years
with the pandemic how valuable the land
is
my husband and i have enjoyed um
countless walks on the street sweet
trail in durham and
have um benefited from the land and
and noticing what the beavers out there
um have been busy doing and it's just an
incredible advantage so
in terms of um how history
is um
uh involved here um we all are aware
that we're not individually responsible
for um
past transgressions um but in the
interest of uh reconciliation and
restorative justice we are responsible
um going forward and i
um think the
we um i know that the lessons we learn
from our indigenous neighbors in terms
of stewardship and protection of the
land is incredibly valuable
there's so much we can learn there's so
many opportunities and i think it starts
with the land acknowledgment thanks so
much
thank you for your testimony will you
take questions
sure if there are any representative
lekkas
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um you said that this is not
just symbolic so i'm wondering
what you see is the the practical um
effects of this beyond symbolism
i think it it speaks to the
acknowledgement itself so sometimes just
opening
people's eyes to the fact that there is
land and we're acknowledging
that there is an indigenous history
and that the
land is more
valuable to all of us if we uh steward
it going forward and as i said i think
of this as a very positive thing and not
as a punitive thing at all we all know
how important the land is even for our
economy
and for our enjoyment so i think it's a
mutual beneficial mutually beneficial
okay thank you
representative pearson
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question you used the word
restorative justice what does that look
like what's the end game here for what
that means to you
um i would not feel comfortable speaking
about the end game because i feel like
that is a
in term that's a
a personal issue for
some people but as i um as i spoke
before i think that the acknowledgement
itself it starts with the
acknowledgement and we're simply
acknowledging um that we are on
indigenous lands and it brings up
the opportunity to learn about how we
going forward
can protect and steward the land so
again it's not um it's restoring things
it's not um it's
it is
um not about
punishment it's about repair
are there any other questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1357 yes please
come up introduce yourself and fill out
a pink card
hello
excuse me
my name is owen emberly i live on
unseated abenaki penacook land here in
concord new hampshire i like what this
gentleman from the kawasaki band said
that this isn't really a debatable issue
it seems like perhaps in this room there
is perhaps some pushback about this but
i would like to represent people of my
age people in my generation who many
cannot be here today because most of us
are working right now but among my
generation this isn't really a debatable
issue it's very well understood that
white americans were not the first
people to inhabit this land i think it's
also fairly evident that white americans
have done some things with the land that
have
jeopardized our economy our climate our
nation i think that there's much wisdom
to be learned from the past i believe
that there's more that could be done but
i think that this is a step in the right
direction i view this bill as a litmus
test for us right now to say how do we
feel about the past how do we feel about
what's happened we can't go back in time
and change what's happened can we do
anything in the present that starts to
correct some of those wrongs and i think
we can i think this bill would be
a terrific step in that right direction
i also think that again speaking from my
generation these are changes that are
going to happen and are going to come
the question is when
as representatives all now right right
now you all have the opportunity to be
the representative body that did this
for new hampshire which would be a great
milestone and i would really appreciate
if this bill passed thank you he'll take
any questions
thank you are there any questions
representative lecka
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um
you stated that
you know you think this would be a good
first step the question is what future
steps do you think it it might lead to
um as the woman who just spoke before me
said as well it's a bit of a loaded
question and i'm not in a position to
make any future steps personally and i
can see why there will be some fear for
that but i don't think there needs to be
i think if the way that our government
is moving is being more open and
accepting and understanding of our past
and understanding of all the citizens
that live here i don't view that as a
scary road that we're working or moving
down i view that as
a potential
benefit to our country and to our state
so i don't know what the end game is
but i do know that what has happened in
the past here in this state has been
morally wrong repugnant terrible
we can't go back and change it but what
can we do now i think this is really a
question of morality that's why i called
it a litmus test within your own hearts
do you think it's right that this land
was stolen from another group of people
do you think it's right that there was
genocide do you think it's right that
as the representative here said
when
the pilgrims landed here they rated
burial mounds to steal food i mean do we
think that's right no i don't think
anyone would think that is right so
i don't have all the answers this is a
sticky thorny question i think it's
great that we can debate it here openly
i don't know exactly what it would lead
to but i do think the opposite side of
the question is what happens if this
doesn't pass what happens if you vote no
if you vote no you're standing for
everything that's happened before that's
not a position i would want to be in
representative wrote
although i agree with this bill i'm
concerned about your presentation
because i've used this bill quite
differently from you and i support it
would you say that the one
way of viewing this bill
and i think it might be the less
confrontational way
is to say that history
includes
all people who lived on this land
there's no judgment on what was done
because we don't know that
there's no
to judge
is not helpful and it is not
a
looking for the right word it's just not
useful
so would you say
that the meaning the intent behind the
bill as is written
is to
acknowledge that
the native american
people who lived on new hampshire in new
hampshire are part of the history
of new hampshire and that bill
acknowledges that
is that fair to
say yes and and i i do understand that
not everyone has to share my
views fully on the subject for this to
pass and i was a little concerned about
you know am i going to overstep my
bounds and come in here and and say this
and do something that would be
detrimental to the bill which i do not
want to happen
but i still think it's a very important
bill to pass
and it
it is what it is it's an acknowledgement
it doesn't have any
immediate effect on the governance of
the state i i think it's the right thing
to do
thank you for your testimony
thank you representative grote thank you
is there anyone
do fill out a pink card sir
so we can record your name
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1357
representative schuett if the gentleman
would take one more question
thank you for taking my question
would you agree that
this bill could be a first step at
current and younger generations
learning about ways to protect the earth
and
help it heal from some of the
things that
previous generations have done to
denigrate the land itself
absolutely i do and when i speak of past
generations it wasn't meant to be with
judgment it was meant to be
as just an assessment of what happened
and i don't think we need to be afraid
of the past i think that we understand
the past we can move forward in a better
way and i think that this uh very firmly
roots us in the past and in the heritage
of this great land that we live on um so
i think it is very positive and i do
apologize if um
i went a little too far like i said this
isn't my bill i'm not the one who wrote
it so i shouldn't be the one to answer
for you know
what could this possibly lead to i think
it is written as
just an acknowledgement a simple
acknowledgement of
the facts of the people who came here
before us and i think it's very positive
for our state i think it'll be a
wonderful thing i think it's a thing
that if this was in new hampshire's laws
to start it off it would be
a benchmark for other states to follow i
love new hampshire i'm a lifelong new
hampshire resident i think new hampshire
is a great state and i would like to
think more people think it's a great
state as well i think this would be a
good step for that thank you
other questions from the committee
all right still seeing none thank you
for your testimony
and i'll close the public hearing
and i want to mention that out of
respect i'm not going to consider it
an executive
to pass this unless someone does an
amendment to fix the spelling
representative schmidt or groter do you
wish to do so i'll be glad to do that
thank you madam chair thank you i think
i think it needs to be done before we
discuss it
okay we have a few minutes before the
next bill so we'll collect our card
you are yes
okay
is
i think we should mandate that everyone
gets at least eight hours
and if you don't you have to pay a fine
that'll help
right
okay
otherwise
every day of the month
that declaration
they're gonna have their own day
is
there we go
um
all right it being 10
10 30 i'm going to open the hearing on
house bill
and i call representative silver to
speak
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee
i had hoped that representative bernardi
who was the principal's prime sponsor be
here but since he's not and i'm a
co-sponsor i will introduce the bill
my name is norman silber i live in
guilford i'm a state rep from belknap
district 2 the towns of guilford and
meredith
that being said
prior to
this day
uh i'm well i'm a member in good
standing of the new hampshire bar and
i've been a member of the new hampshire
bar since 2008
and i've been a member of the florida
bar since
scary thought
over the course of my career i spent a
great deal of time
on real estate transactions and i've
handled hundreds of real estate
transactions purchases and sales
this bill everyone tells you that their
bill is simple this bill is truly simple
it only takes a few lines on the on the
back page
one of the things that i've always
concerned me is okay first of all
even though i'm a lawyer and i know a
lot of people don't like lawyers and i
share that view from experience
real estate agents real estate brokers
and sales people particularly don't like
lawyers because they usually view
lawyers as deal killers not deal makers
deal breakers not deal makers
i've always been i thought a deal maker
one of the things that's always
concerned me is when a client comes to
me and says after the fact they've
signed this piece of paper this is
printed form that was presented to them
in a transaction and they were told
don't worry it's just a standard form
that is the alarm bells go off i have
never
treated a printed form and you can take
a you can take a piece of paper nowadays
it's easy to make a printed form out of
anything in the old days it was a little
harder but
printed forms
i've always taken the view that i still
want to read it and i have no problem
with taking in those days a ruler and a
pen and crossing through lines and
marking them up and putting an addendum
on and making changes everything in a
real estate transaction is negotiable
notwithstanding the fact the real estate
agent will say in this listing agreement
to list your property for sale
there's no changes accepted by the
multiple listing service you have to
sign it as is and it's just a standard
form that's a lot of nonsense
you can make changes on the thing and
the multiple listing services are happy
to put your property in there
the the problem that this addresses is
that
not all listing agreements which is the
basically your contract with a real
estate broker says that here's what i
want to sell my property for this price
or better uh these are the basic terms
will i finance part of the purchase
price or not uh and
sometimes not not every listing
agreement but some listing agreements
have a provision buried in the standard
form
that says that the broker is authorized
to sign a sale contract that meets the
terms of the listing agreement
well
so by the time a person comes to the
lawyer
they've already signed this form and
they say
that the broker has already signed my
sale contract and there's portions of
the contract i don't like
well at that point it's all it's
basically too late you're euro you're up
the creek without a paddle you really
don't have much choice because you've
already granted the right to sign that
contract to the real estate broker
um
what this basically says what the bill
says is that only the owner
can sign the contract of sale
or
can use a power of attorney a formal
power of attorney that grants to their
agent called an attorney in fact
the express right to sign the contract
of real estate
so
the people who
most people
who dislike lawyers meeting all of us
do not
seek out lawyers every day for
everything they do
usually you sequel you gotta may get a
lawyer involved in the purchase sale of
real estate maybe a divorce maybe an
estate plan but most people if they're
smart stay away from lawyers
highly recommended
the
the problem here is
principally dealing with
the average person
doesn't know what they're signing even
though the law says that it's presumed
that you know what you're signing
and so somewhere buried in this standard
form
there may be this language
which
sometimes it works out and sometimes it
doesn't and
while it may if it doesn't work out and
it produces lawsuits and stuff like that
i guess that's good for lawyers but it's
it's not good for the people the average
person who wants to sell their property
it's really pretty simple you hire a
broker they bring you offers you review
the offers if you like the offer you
sign the contract very simple why should
you give up your rights to review the
offers and give it to some other person
whose principal interest is in closing
the transaction collecting a commission
that's their interest your interest is
in selling your property for
whatever terms you you have set
so
and keep in mind that real estate
brokers in in our state as in most
states can be in a variety acting in a
variety of capacities they can be in a
fiduciary capacity they can be a
transaction broker there's a variety of
of of approaches so what i'm telling you
this is sort of a peak behind the
curtain
as it were from a lawyer's perspective
perspective as having handled many many
many
real estate purchases and sales over the
years i think this is a good consumer
protection bill it is really truly
nonpartisan
it will protect the little people
particularly the elderly of our state
and those who
don't run out and get a lawyer every
time they're they're thinking about
doing something
a lot of real estate transactions in our
state are handled without a lawyer
the broker
brings he brings the contract the
contract gets signed it's closed with a
title agent lawyers may not be involved
you know
there's different views as to whether
that's a sound way to approach the
transactions but if you're just you know
dealing with a small home or something
like that there's probably little harm
involved but the elderly can
not not know what they're signing but
they sign something that legally binds
them all we're trying to do is to say
you need to know exactly what you're
agreeing to or give a power of attorney
with an express grant of the right to
sign the contract
i'll be happy to take any questions
thank you representative silber are
there questions from the committee
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
representative silber
i see in the language
several places it mentions power of
attorney but i also see
on behalf of an owner by an attorney in
fact what does that mean
a power of attorney is a formal document
where an individual which is called the
principal
designates an agent to act for them
and that agent is legally called their
attorney in fact
that's it's just
legal gobbledygook
it's just
a specific language
attorney but i had not seen an attorney
in fact before thank you
it's legal gobbledygook it's it's so
that you have to go hire a lawyer to
explain it to
you thank you rep representative silber
for providing us free legal service i
hope that's not a violation of your bar
agreement
i don't think i'm on the favored list of
the borrower these days all right other
questions representative scitec
representative fellows was first
um thank you this is just kind of a
follow-up to that last question
so for the power of
for the power of attorney
does that need to be um witnessed with
by um
notary yeah and and is the same and what
about the contract does that happen
if the contract of sale does not need to
be witnessed or notarized
a listing agreement does not need to be
witnessed or notarized the listing room
where you hire the broker
there's a there's some rsas that deal
with a power of attorney and what the
requirements for a power of attorney are
in new hampshire uh i would be remiss to
try to tell you that i am totally
familiar with that so uh but basically
the power of attorney typically is very
is a formalistic document that has i
state your name uh hereby appoint
the person the power as my attorney in
fact to do the following things
and typically and no others you can have
a general power of attorney to do
everything on my behalf you can have a
specific power of attorney and
what happens is the power of attorney
on
a power when you'd if you pass away and
you've issued a power of attorney the
power of attorneys disappear they are
null and void when you die
now new hampshire i do know that the new
hampshire law and powers of attorney
makes all powers of attorney durable
which means that even though you are
incapacitated legally
which in most states in many states
would mean that your powers of attorney
are null and void
a durable power continues even after
legal incapacity so unless your power of
attorney in new hampshire says that it's
not durable it's presumed to be durable
too much information probably yes thank
you representative silver yes i simply
wanted to know
in terms of of the um notary
does does a notary you have do you have
to have it notarized to have a power of
attorney in
representative fellows representative
silver said he's not familiar with the
laws of the state but he did reference
them so
i'm not sure you don't know okay thank
you
questions okay seeing none thank you
very much thank you very much for your
attention
obviously i want this to pass
i call janet archibald
thank you representative mcguire and
thank you committee members for hearing
my testimony my name is janan archibald
i'm here representing myself
to be closer to the microphone please
okay
from 2008 to 2020 i owned a small
business specializing in personal
property appraisals and senior
downsizing
i was also a licensed new hampshire real
estate agent for part of that time
my job afforded me the opportunity to
work with senior clientele as they move
from their large homes into continuing
care retirement centers and independent
living facilities
during my tenure as a downsizing
professional i became very involved in
my clients lives and bore witness to
situations involving elder exploitation
and abuse
one may think of physical abuse when
hearing the term elder abuse but the u.s
justice department defines elder abuse
as caregiver negligence financial
exploitations physical abuse and
psychological abuse
the national adult protective services
organization herein referred to as nafsa
breaks down elder financial exploitation
to nine categories one of those
categories pertains to real estate and
the definition states real estate
involving unauthorized sales transfers
or changes to property titles
may include unauthorized or invalid
changes to estate documents
nafsa also lists abuse of power of
attorney as a form of financial abuse
the aftermath of elder abuse or
exploitation doesn't end after an
incident reports and studies have shown
that seniors lose 2.6 billion dollars a
year due to financial abuse
elderly victims of financial abuse are
three times more likely to die and four
times more likely to enter a nursing
home
and almost one in 10 financial abuse
victims will turn to medicaid as a
direct result of their monies being
stolen from them
for the first time in history the census
bureau projects the population over the
age of 65 by 2023 will be the largest
demographic in the united states
well outnumbering children
one in every five u.s residents will be
at retirement age
to those of us who take the time to
advocate for senior rights this is a
scary and daunting statistic
while the system of elder care may be
structured with the best of intentions
getting care and transparency in many
areas requires a high level of advocacy
to get the services and treatment as
required by law
i don't see the need for advocates going
away by 2030 or beyond
if anything there's going to be an
increased need to help the aging
population and i'm fearful there won't
be enough of us advocate types to go
around
in lieu of advocates a big stride we can
make as stewards of humanity is
establishing sound legislation that
promotes honesty integrity and
transparency
this is why i am in support of hb 1344.
simply put this bill does not allow
anyone to sign a purchase and sale
contract on behalf of another person
without a power of attorney on file
as a realtor this would seem obvious to
me a licensed realtor is bound to a
strict code of ethics and in this code
of ethics it defines standards of
practice that address contracts and the
role of the realtor
this legislation would be a nice
accompaniment to standard of practice
9.2 which states realtors shall make
reasonable efforts to explain the nature
and disclose the specific terms of
contractual relationships being
established prior to it being agreed to
by a contracting party
perhaps even more applicable is the
protection this bill would be would
provide against unauthorized third
parties signing documents on behalf of
the seller such as guardians relatives
and or friends or household helped since
over two-thirds of elder abuse is
initiated by spouses or family members
as a former senior movementer who has
moved hundreds of clients in new
hampshire i can say the most valuable
asset the vast majority of my clients
owned was their homes
most needed this money for retirement
and down payments to move into ccrcs or
independent living facilities
for most this was the last real estate
transaction they would ever enter into
and the proceeds of the sale were vital
for maintaining their financial
independence
the process of signing a purchase and
sale agreement is easier than it's ever
been the documents are available online
in electronic format such as docusign
and dot loop
theoretically a legally binding document
can be designed in a couple of minutes
sitting in front of a computer
while i cannot speak to the legality and
available recourse to individuals who
are victims of a fraudulent contract
signing i can say that i have witnessed
the anguish and frustration that clients
have had to endure in the aftermath of
such an incident
resolving conflicts like these can take
months and years to go through the court
system
generally time is not viewed as a
commodity that can be thrown around
within this population
and the will to fight injustices is just
not as intense
that's why i ask you committee members
to take this small step towards ensuring
we have sound legislation on the books
that protects the interests of our
seniors and vulnerable population in the
state of new hampshire please vote in
support and not to pass on hb 1344.
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
you're obviously reading from a prepared
document can you provide that to the
committee yes i did email it to all the
committee members
thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for your time
chris norwood
good morning madam chair members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak for the record my name is chris
norwood i am the 2022 public policy
chair with the new hampshire association
of realtors
we are in support of the bill and i
wasn't planning on testifying but there
are a couple items i just wanted to
clarify
um and just mention to our support i
think for all the reasons the past
speakers meant that this is a
prudent
action
not to have realtors have a power of
attorney i can say in my
20 or so years of
career i've never been
granted a power of attorney by my
clients to also enter into a purchase
and sales agreement on their behalf i
just think it's a prudent thing to keep
a separation of church and state so to
speak
but a couple points for clarity
first in a past life about five years
ago i worked on the forms committee for
the commercial board of realtors and i
can state that there is no
standard in those forms that speaks to a
power of attorney um and i'm not just
i'm not saying that it has not happened
but what i am saying is is that it would
take an act upon a licensee to
affirmatively put that language into the
additional provisions section
of a listing agreement and again
not disputing that that might have
happened but i just want to make the
committee aware that there is no
standard language in the realtor forms
that that grants a poa or an attorney in
fact to a licensee
uh the second second piece
while i wasn't planning on testifying i
i did prepare uh because i had the same
questions as some of the committee
members did relative to
uh a
a power of attorney needing to be um
notarized thank you so i'll just read
briefly from rsa
hyphen e colon 105
to
letter b
a power of attorney to convey real
estate must be signed open parens other
than by electronic signature closed
parens
by the principal or in the principal's
conscious presence by another individual
directed by the principal to sign the
principal's name on the general power of
attorney and must be acknowledged before
a notary public or other individual
authorized by law to take
acknowledgement
so
again in our in the realtor's viewpoint
um unless that listing agreement or had
a notarization
the the power of attorney that would
have been granted in that listing
agreement
wouldn't have passed muster um
again supporting the bill we just wanted
to clarify those points and i'm happy to
entertain any questions of the committee
thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
questions of the committee
representative site
mr norwood if this requires if this is
not a standard check on a
real estate form that it actually has to
be inscribed
added as a codicil or whatever and
notarized
is this bill necessary
the the second half of the bill would
confirm that you couldn't do it in one
single document uh representative so uh
any contract let me just read this one
i guess what i would say to this
representative is
the bill uh
what the bill would would codify is that
there would have to be two separate
documents and so while yes someone would
have to insert that into the listing
agreement into your question we would
have to include a a
notarization to our listing agreement
which doesn't presently exist
um this bill would signify to say hey
you just can't do that all in one piece
of paper it's got to be a separate piece
of paper that would clearly draw
attention to the fact
that you are granting a poa to
a licensee i think that would be the
intent
of or not the intent of the bill i think
that that would be the practice of
law if the bill were to be passed
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question uh if this bill
passes
the previous speaker mentioned a
standard of practice i guess the
realtors performed
upon passage of this bill were to be
adopted into that standard of practice
for realtors so they would know about it
so thank you representative for the
question i can say
those
those standards of practice are part of
the national association of realtors for
which we get
training on every three years but the
adoption of those standards of practices
take place at a national level
so the realtors within the state of new
hampshire
don't necessarily have the right to
amend that
so
and this may not be what you're asking
but i think that there may be examples
whereby realtors uh would still
have the separate power of attorney
because that's clearly what their
clients wished if if that makes sense
for all parties involved
follow-up if i may uh
400 representatives
fluffer over bills
how would the realtors know what we're
doing here and what our intentions are
in this bill will have it down to the
relative
thank you representative so as far as
the training goes i can tell you that
i've had numerous conversations as chair
of public policy with the educators in
our um
in our state who train on the 40 hours
of pre-qualification as well as the the
ongoing uh qualifications 15 hours every
two years
the educators have been very much
involved in the public policy committee
and they would be aware of the bill
are there other questions
yes representative allegra
thank you madam chair
representative o'brien brings up a good
point about this information filtering
down to the people practicing this but
am i correct in
i don't think you need to be an attorney
to to see this but am i correct in
assuming that regardless of whether or
not it filters down
if this law goes into effect
it would protect clients
essentially nullifying any accidental or
nefarious application of these kinds of
power of attorney that hidden powers of
attorney i mean that's what the law is
going to say
thank you representative for the
question and as i stated prior my
personal belief though not a lawyer
would be that that power of attorney
that was otherwise put into a listing
agreement wouldn't be in effect because
it was not notarized but i do feel it's
uh
as an attorney friend once said to me
it's a belt and suspenders type approach
right so it's it's kind of
covering both bases
representative schuett thank you madam
chair um
i
i thank you for the
sight of the other
um rsa
regarding power of attorney
and i don't know if you know the answer
to this but it sounds as though
that power of attorney if it's notarized
could be granted to someone
other than a practicing attorney is that
correct
yes representative thank you for the
question i i have worked with
parties who have had a power of attorney
who are not attorneys who are
relatives and so forth uh or you know
just otherwise a trusted individual to
the to the seller
thank you
any other questions
okay seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you madam chair
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1344
okay seeing none i'm going to close the
public here
so
okay
are you on there
why
okay
sounds like you did holy cow
you could have come and listened to the
uh
that was today
has been
oh
is
but she
okay
is
i think that's the
all right
is
the payments from taxes
okay
i guess
this transactions
is
surgery
yeah yeah
okay
yes
his wife
facilities
is
started today
actually
i guess
[Music]
is
a boss
it's a great job
right which is uh
today
okay
all right
it having reached 10 15
i'm good
excuse me
it's 11 15 and i'm failing my uh
clock rating
so i'm opening the hearing on house bill
1354 and calling the sponsor
representative acton
thank you madam chair thank you all for
your time
hp
1354 was a bill that passed
before covid and then like so many
others just disappeared into the
mess that existed back then
but basically this is a
change to the rules that
allows
licensed real estate agents who then go
inactive to continue to
collect annualized or periodic payments
so give an example
several years ago i was a active real
estate agent
if i was involved in in selling
commercial leases or renting apartments
or so so forth a lot of times the
compensation structure
is set up that you
get paid per lease and you will receive
more payment if that lease renews in the
next year
uh so there's deferred compensation
packages but the problem is that if i go
inactive
and no longer active um
actively in the career of um
real estate age being an agent
i'm no longer able to collect those
annualized payments so you have to you
have to
forfeit the payments of your payment
structure because of the
the rules uh in the um
real estate licensure
so this is basically uh we're bringing
it back up and um
to run it back through here and um we i
have two people that are going to be
testifying at least two um
um ann flanagan is a well-known uh
person in in the industry and does a lot
of training and so forth and then we
have a representative from the oplc to
answer any questions
but um like i said um we we're here to
try it again and it it's really not
controversial and it really it'll help
the
uh income of people like myself will get
into the industry and then for whatever
reason you you don't carry it on you get
your your payments that you expect into
the future
that's all i have to say today
thank you representative broder has a
question can you answer
absolutely
so i can understand that if you are an
agent and you are actively working to
get a
lease fulfilled
but if you retire and you or you you let
your license expire and you no longer
are able to do that
how does that
pertain to you getting paid for
something
well if the if the contract that you're
working on
for payment
suggests that you or stipulates that you
get paid each time that lease is renewed
then that's that's a payment structure a
legal payment structure that can be made
contractually um
and it would make sense if you in and
this is common practice
that if someone you find the lease to
lease a building a building or an
apartment
renews that lease then uh
there's
a number of compensation structures that
allow you to collect each time that that
lease is renewed but you can't do that
if you happen to go inactive
follow
up so
[Music]
i can understand how if the same person
renews the lease
that would be the case but let's say
that the purge release
uh okay so the lease is always between
an individual the same individual what
you're saying is if you were
you were the real estate agent that
established that initial relationship
with that individual
and the
owner of the
property and that lease was renewed
continuous
on
was renewed then
you're asking for payments for that but
if that there was a
that's right because any other
arrangement between two different
individuals would not be a renewal
correct yeah if there's any change to to
who is leasing or or something like that
um but these are these are structured
payments that are agreed contractually
up front
and that we would like to be able to
enable um it's it's been
this has been
described to me as housekeeping and and
we'll we'll hear from oplc and see what
they think about thank you okay
uh
representative acton i want to warn you
about using the word housekeeping it
usually means we're opening a can of
worms
okay thank you um
fairly new and that's the first one for
me no problem representative seistek has
you said that your deferred payment plan
uh
ends if you become dormant retire
right
your ability to receive payment
is only allowed
currently if you are an active licensee
yes
if i'm a follow-up
you're talking is this an operation of
law or an operation of contract
well
it's an operation of contract based on
the rules uh that are stipulated in the
uh oplc real estate licensing
and and the br the
i'm sure there's people who know more
about this than me
ready to testify
where i am going is if this is a matter
of contract you shouldn't sign a
contract
like that you should get a contract that
says your payments persist you didn't
die i mean well
sometimes you know people's lives change
and they and they um can no longer
practice real estate and they they want
to go inactive so you can keep your
license active you're just not actively
practicing
and we would like to see that as long as
you're an inactive status that you can
collect on the
payments that you're you're contracted
to get
representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question
so my prior life when i lived in
pittsburgh pennsylvania i sold real
estate for 17 years
and when i moved here and i put my
license in an inactive status
i also put it in referral status so that
all of the listings that i had in the
pipeline per se
i would at least be able to
compensate for some of the the funds
that i had put out
so i'm trying to find here where i do
see you know making a referrals for
commission other compensation can you
explain
wouldn't that be the same thing so if
you put your license
in active status is it the same thing as
putting it in referral therefore you
would still be able to make a percentage
of that because
i'm sorry
yeah i'm um
i'm unfamiliar with the referral
the the referral um part of this and
so i i would have to
defer to
either ann or or the oplc people to give
you a definitive answer on that
okay thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
calling your attention to page two
um
line one
strikes the word reciprocity and
replaces it with recognition then later
on in line on line screen four
it says if already granted a license
through reciprocity or recognition
those two handlings of the
terminology seem to be inconsistent with
each other so um
are you redefining uh
you're replacing reciprocity with
recognition in line one on page two but
then you
you you just add recognition later on
that doesn't seem to work to me
yes i
once again i'm gonna
i
will defer to someone who can give you a
more definitive answer on that and if it
needs an amendment we can do that but uh
we'll see hey are there other questions
for representative acton
yes representative
thank you
i've only had to lease a property once
and so my experience is limited but when
we did we had to move out of state
and our real estate agents still
performed services for us
for example even when we had the same
tenant
you know the papers were delivered to me
from our agent
if a repair needed to be made or the
property needed to be inspected in other
words
our agent was providing a service for us
and that continuity existed
are
when you say inactive
services still be being provided it
sounds like no
um
or is there no service being provided
thank
you thank you for the question i i i
basically um
in this instance
when you go inactive you're not allowed
to do anything
related to
being a real estate agent
and so that you are no longer
able to to provide
services such as that
but what we're talking about is if you
if the
agent who brings in
um
the the customer signs a lease
um in the
business agreement is that you get paid
x amount
for each renewed lease
then that can continue to be paid any
any ancillary services beyond that
um based on law you're not allowed to
provide them as a as the
inactive agent but you uh what we're
trying to do is make it so that you can
get paid on uh contractually of what you
um
what you earned from bringing in um
people
inciting leases
representative schuett
thank you madam chair um
representative if you uh turn in your
license
i'm seeing references here to
other things that would continue but i
don't see specific reference to fees
that are necessary if you remain
licensed
or would this
would you still be paying fees
as
when you go inactive you have you have
um
there's a set of rules that you follow
to to remain
as an inactive status
but still in the system whereas if you
let it lapse for i believe over a year
you you are out you have to actually
retake the test to come back in
so this is inactive status is
is you're kind of a
reserve but you're not actively um
working in the business at that point
but you're kind of you're you're it's
basically if we were to get pregnant or
um
you know in my case get become a state
rep you
you can't dedicate the time it takes to
be in the to be an active um
state or active real estate agent but
you want to be able to go back to that
in the future so it's more of a
temporary
suspending of of active status you need
to go and inactive but i i'm still
required to take
um
ceu training and so forth to remain in
the
inactive status
follow-up question so if if you um
go inactive and you have exceeded the
time for the fee that you've paid
those fees help pay for the education
and so forth that you receive
so
how are you covering that expense well i
paid for the the training myself
it's a private um
see the in most businesses
you're you the professionals pay for the
training themselves
in some cases some professions the
employer does but in most of them i
think it seems it's their own licensee's
responsibility
thank you so there is a renewal fee and
so forth there are fees that we pay to
oplc
to keep the remain uh the
inactive status alive
and then you know like i said i did have
to take a
um
a fairly involved course that cost i
believe uh
50 or 75 dollars to to to stay on an
active status so you don't just walk
away from it and stay you have to still
keep within the system
other questions
representative marsh
yes thank you dennis it's good to see
you again is there a procedure to go
back on active status if you wanted to
do that
you have to um
reapply and and uh re re-enable your
your uh
license and then you have to keep up
with your training that's the big thing
and if you don't do the training then
you can't do it you got to go back out
and take it start from scratch
all right follow up madam chair but if
you've kept up with your training it's a
fairly straightforward process to go
back to active yes that's and i'm on
inactive so i just took the class and
and um hopefully we'll go back to it as
soon as i can but it is easy and it's
actually
i mean
the oplc real estate
section was was excellent i feel um the
people are responsive i i quickly got my
license we've seen licensing problems in
other areas but i quickly got my license
i there's a plethora of good courses to
take all over the state
and i took mine remotely because of
covid and so it's a very
um well-run
section and it's i think working very
well for the real estate industry in new
hampshire
thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
i have a
question for you regarding page
one of
the document
which seems to me
to be defective again
looking at
lines um
20 and 21
you say
let me apply for your new hampshire
license with the same equivalent state
status as
currently licensed in the qualifying
jurisdiction by first taking
the new hampshire portion of the
licensing examination
and the word taking is used again
subsequently
and i don't think that it does any good
to take the exam unless you pass it so
why don't you just say passing the exam
you can't pass it without taking it so
i i think representative schmidt that's
something that mr schumer care will be
able to address better than
representative acton
that's correct thank you madam chair
thank you it is a valid point but yes
other questions for representative acton
no then i will call thank you for your
testimony and i will call mr shoemaker
to explain all these details to us
briefly
if you like certainly
ann flanagan
hi my name is anne flanagan
i'm jack flanagan's sister um
he originally introduced this bill
before please speak come on mike please
can you hear me okay um my name's ann
flanagan uh jack flanagan's my brother
he originally introduced this bill when
he was a representative
he decided not to run this time so
representative acton was good enough to
to do that for us
i used to be the investigator for the
state of new hampshire real estate
commission for 22 years retired now i
teach the classes
i think we were getting a little hung up
on the whole rental thing here a few
minutes ago but the two key parts of
that first the first paragraph and the
second paragraph are totally different
but um the word on line four that's
crossed out receiving and then later
after that bracket making
the way the law is currently worded
let's say you
gave a referral for a listing or
something like that while you were
active
or rentals but mostly selling um and
then the way it's worded now let's say
you decide to go inactive or just let
your license go or something like that
and get into something else
you can get you could not get paid for
that referral or that listing or that
buyer client or lease or whatever you
did the way it's currently worded so by
exchanging the word receiving to making
it just means if you're not active then
you cannot make any new business
versus
what this what this is it is sort of
housekeeping it allows you to get paid
for something you did while you were
active
new hampshire does not recognize um
if you put your license in a referral
that's considered active in a referral
division as you were talking about
before
um
so
that i think that's it is sort of just
house cleaning
it it allows i guess you don't like that
word or something but i'm not sure
it does allow you get paid for what you
did while you were active even if you
were no longer active or if you're
working for another broker they don't
have to pay you through your new broker
they can just pay you directly for what
work you did while you were active now
the second paragraph is more substantive
um
whoever mentioned that about passing
that that that is a very good point
rather than taking
um somebody had a issue on the second
page why it says reciprocity was that
you yes that that that's a good point
but i can explain it
the reason it still says the word
reciprocity is because some people
already got their license to reciprocity
so if we if we pass this then
there'll be people who get their license
through recognition but we already have
people who got it through reciprocity so
if their out-of-state license that this
was based on gets suspended or revoked
you know you need that in there it needs
to say reciprocity or recognition you
need both of them in there because
you don't want to make make it so that
if they got it previously through
reciprocity that though they can go get
their out-of-state license revoked and
it won't affect their their new
hampshire license
so so would it be fair to say
that in the past we issued licenses by
reciprocity but now an out-of-state
person would get a license by
recognition correct there would no
longer be reciprocity only recognition
but as i just mentioned you still have
to deal with people who already have it
through reciprocity if their license out
of state gets revoked
that would affect their new hampshire
license
if i had to make any suggestion
on that second paragraph about the
recognition
on line 27 it says non-resident
salesperson or broker applicants
i would change that word non-resident to
recognition applicants
the word
non-resident unfortunately is one of
those words that unfortunately has more
than one meaning the intent of the
meaning here of non-resident is somebody
who has an out-of-state
license
but that word gets misinterpreted
to mean
they know they don't live in new
hampshire so let's say they had a
license in massachusetts they wanted to
get their new hampshire license which is
very very common
let's say they've already moved to new
hampshire you don't want them to be
denied recognition because of that
because what difference does it make
they have an active good standing
license in massachusetts what difference
does it makes if they
get get their new hampshire license
before they move or after they move to
new hampshire
it's just one of those words that has
more than one meeting and i've seen it
get
mis mis-um
interpreted
you know i would change the word
non-resident to recognition sales person
and broker applicant
and
the um i know i've talked to people at
the op
plc and they will talk about as well
this is something that they're
desperately wanting to happen because
they spend so much time dealing with
these out-of-state applicants who want
to get a new hampshire license this
would just make the whole process clean
uniform in nature whereas now it's so
subjective um
you know um i
i think that um
there's no reason not to pass this
yeah thank you would you answer some
questions sure representative rhodes and
then
thank you madam chairman
okay so i i read this a little bit more
after my my prior question so the
previous speaker the representative
spoke to
basically we all understand
you kind of put your license aside
you're busy doing other things
so is this so is this saying
that they are going to receive all of
the commission compensation it was
agreed to
even though they're actively not
still maintaining and doing what needs
to be done and another realtor is
that's an excellent point because
most agents when they actively work for
a broker have an as you know an
independent contractor agreement and
they vary
that independent contractor for one
office may say if you leave you get
nothing okay and you sign that or you
leave you're getting nothing but
the more kinder agent-friendly offices
their independent contractor agreement
might say
if you leave we will compensate you up
to six months or a year or something
from when you actually procure the
action
but the problem with the law the way is
written now let's say you had a big
listing a million dollar listing and
for some reason you went inactive maybe
you had medical problems family issues
whatever you decided to go inactive
and that that million dollar listing
that you brought into the office sells
and the broker says oh i can't pay you
because you're no longer active
well why shouldn't you get paid for
something you worked and did the work
for while you were active that's what
this law is accomplishing
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
ms flanagan with reference to the change
you suggested on line 27
would there be an instance that would
apply
that someone could have that
previous term
reciprocity
also apply to that line should that be
included in that language also
if we make that change no because
the the reason the purpose of this to is
to eliminate reciprocity going forward
and go with recognition so going forward
no you don't want to let people apply
for reciprocity so if someone
were previously under that
language of reciprocity
this would not apply to them
correct because they already got their
license to reciprocity thank you
i'm sure there's going to be a
transition process through the real
estate real estate board thank you
are there other questions from the
committee
can i make one more point that i forgot
to mention yes please um
the effective date
uh oplc can probably talk better about
this
this law is probably going to have some
accompanying rules to it
you know maybe some education
requirements for these out of state
applicants on the new hampshire you know
specific regulations
i'm not sure how long the rulemaking
process takes nowadays i mean is 60 days
enough for that um would 90 days be a
better
thing i think they can speak to that
better than i can
we'll be sure to ask
all right thank you for your testimony
okay
is shoemaker
good morning madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is joe
shoemaker i'm the division director for
licensing and board administration at
oplc
i think representative acton and miss
flanagan did a good job
i don't know if there's much else i can
add i'll
add a few things but then happy to
answer any questions you may have
um again as was mentioned this bill was
brought forward last session i think or
maybe it was a session before
and i think had full support
it really i won't use the housekeeping
language i'll use
loopholes if you will
you know we get many requests on the two
things that this bill does
the referral fees just to clarify
representative rhodes
this doesn't mandate that
companies pay those
fees or commissions
it just allows them to
um so again
it would still be agreement by agreement
but until now unless this changes
they're not even allowed to do that
under the current
current law
and again we regularly have those
questions come in to the oplc through
our customer service group
and
you know fully support that change
secondly
the questions around reciprocity versus
recognition
i think miss flanagan answered those
those well
one of the current challenges we have we
only had reciprocity agreements from
what i'm told with about four states i
think it was maine massachusetts and a
few new england states
in a couple of those instances
we don't have those agreements anymore
we just somehow
they were signed
20 years ago previous to oplc we
couldn't find them um we've gone back
through meeting minutes and tried i
think at one point we
we you know recognized that they've been
voted on a meeting minute so when we
went back to a couple of those states
they really didn't have any interest in
writing new agreements with us
so again this just really going forward
eliminates us having to work with states
to come up with an agreement and and
oplc really supports um you know
portability of licensing overall if you
will and this gets to that we no longer
have to come up with agreements again
if you are licensed in another state we
would recognize that license
the two things
of course that you passed the new
hampshire correct specific
block part which is unique which is in
here correct
the two things that were brought up
earlier i would support the language
change that was brought up from
representative schmidt adding in the
language that they would need to pass
the exam to be licensed
i
we have to look at it i i'm not opposed
to having them uh start the application
process as long as they tell us but they
wouldn't be able to be issued obviously
until they passed that exam
uh the second one was uh
ms flanagan's comment about changing the
non-resident language uh on line 27 on
the first page um
you know i'm fine with that too uh
changing that to
license recognition you know recognition
um
i think that's that's all i have again
happy to answer any questions anybody
may have
thank you for your testimony
representative blechus has a question
um previous speaker brought up the issue
of effective date um is 60 days all
right yes well i i would prefer the 90
days i had that in my notes i was going
to bring that up
again
when this passes we would do interim
rules
before we finalize but i think the 90
days would be
a little bit easier so i'd prefer the 90
but if you prefer to stay with 60 we can
work with that as well okay
further question
um as far as the recognition change
let's be clear on the language
um
would it just be replacing the word
non-resident with recognition and that's
it or would there be any other
wording change required there
on line 27
page one
yeah i would say those recognized uh
i mean the sentence is
this section applies to
non-resident salesperson or broker
applicants would it be
you know
questions what exact wording would work
there
so i think you can just cross out the
word non-resident and the sentence will
work fine
yes
there are
many people in new england who have
licenses from more than one state not
necessarily the one they live in so
agreed i think just removing it works
okay great thank you
okay
other questions
thank you for your testimony is there
anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1354
yes server
madam chair members of the committee my
name again for the record is chris
norwood i'm the 2022 public policy chair
for the new hampshire association of
realtors
and we support the bill i
much like the previous bill i don't have
a prepared written testimony
but certainly would ask anybody to
answer any i'd be happy to answer any
questions from a licensee's perspective
uh specifically uh on the upper section
and the lower section i think most of
the questions have been answered uh i
think the only other item that i had in
my notes is that uh there uh there is a
currently a new makeup of the new
hampshire real estate commission and
i don't believe the realtors have had a
chance to connect with
the current members of the real estate
commission but it sounds like uh by mr
shoemaker's testimony that in general
oplc is supportive
so again happy to answer any questions
from a licensee's perspective
thank you for your testimony
questions
good timing on your part all the
questions have been answered
all right
thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to test just a quick question
adam you called yourself the 2022 policy
uh the public policy chair for the new
hampshire association of realtors
representative thank you
okay
thank you madam chair oh thank you any
other
testimony
all right
i will close the public hearing on house
bill 1354 we will resume at 1pm
and this will be going to subcommittee
for a fine-tooth comb on some of the
language
oh
ears
thank you for
doing that
stop
jeff take your time
okay
this is happening all day today i'm like
confused
uh
yeah that makes sense
um
is
now
um
okay
is
foreign
my perspective
i've watched
um
don't take any questions
that was on education
this year
uh
fingers
yes
mr
um
thank you
uh
right is
last week
so
we're talking
latinos
uh
um
is
facebook
people
well
there's
several times
okay
wow
oh
so
stuff
oh
okay
uh
um
is
a um
your your bill is up first so i'm
recognizing you yes
house bill 1182
i'm opening the public hearing and
recognizing the prime sponsor
representative schmidt
good afternoon minimum share
we'll get the volume terms today
so i will um
be brief because we have oplc people are
here
and this is as we've already experienced
with a couple of other issues
this is something that
the chair and i and some of the other
senior members
of edna
have been working on because
we think that
the overall concept of
management of boards can be improved
by letting the
the experts at oplc
experts in administration law the the
statutes rules and so forth
focus on their areas of expertise and
the stakeholders the practitioners will
focus on their area of expertise which
is their particular profession
craft or occupation in this case
court reporters
and
i'm a big fan
be quite candid and upfront
excuse me
i'm a big fan of court reporters because
as you as some of you know all of you
should know
i'm on the jail car
and
we have to have a very very
accurate record of our proceedings and
so
for a long while up until quite recently
we were
assisted in every one of our hearings
with
a court reporter
taking a verbatim
uh making a
verbatim transcript
of our our actual
our activities
and our actual uh words
and i've looked at it and
and they're much much better than what
then it can be done by a tape recorder
and a transcriber who doesn't wasn't
there doesn't know what's going on so
court reporters produce the best kind of
record you can get
that's reasonable without having
because
even though the record that we are
creating right now with our video cam
and our words and so forth
you can go back and you can listen
and hear the people say it as well as
what they're saying
but you have to have
you have to find the right spot
and in a in a printed document that you
can analyze and so forth so court
reporters are a big deal um and but i'm
not going to get in the mechanics of the
bill you all can read
but what we are doing is
uh letting the old plc
as i say
play a greater role in the
administrative end they're not trying to
take away
the expertise of any profession
and we had the same situation
a couple of weeks ago with one of our
other
experimental
changes and and
um the director executive director is
here miss courtney and she will
talk about things from her end of things
so i'll take any questions you might
have if you have any but that's it's the
fundamental theme of how we we're doing
it
with
a more focused
application of the expertise on both
sides of the issue
thank you representative schmidt are
there any questions from the committee
representative scitec
representative schmidt you mentioned
kraft's
occupations and professions did you mean
to exclude guilds
representative scitec
you can't impugn his motives
i will only say in response to that that
when i was living in germany many years
ago i was acting as an interpreter for
the oecd not the oplc oecd the
organization of economic cooperation and
development
and the word inun came up
i knew german very well but i'd never
heard the word inum before i didn't know
what it was
and i found out it was the german word
for guild
um and
an award that was somewhat out of the
german lesson
are there any other questions
representative
ordinarily i charge big bucks for my
german lessons oh
thank you i mean i'm i'm looking at this
and i know i think it's the same as the
existing statute but the list of
qualifications
seem to be pretty general and have
nothing directly to do with being a
court reporter am i missing something
here
because it's no this is this is
for greater efficacy and efficiency of
oversight of this particular board and
we we
uh representative
um
representative
what's your name again representative
goalie
representative goalie representative
stuart
representative mcguire and myself
as you know longer serving members of
oplc are
doing this with a couple of small boards
no there's no
we're not picking on any board we're
dealing with small boards which have in
some cases difficulties with quorums and
so forth
my question was somewhat different thank
you i'll ask it separately thank you
any other questions
thank you very much representative
schmidt
director courtney
sorry
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record lindsey
courtney executive director office of
professional licensure and certification
thank you representative schmidt for
bringing this bill forward
oplc is here today in support of house
bill 1182 which would essentially
convert the board of court reporters
over to an advisory board
the basis for seeking out this
legislative change is really just to um
to come up with a solution with what we
believe we've been having a quorum
issues with that particular board
as the committee is no doubt aware the
licensing boards have independent
regulatory authority um
to promulgate rules
to issue licenses and also to conduct
discipline and when a board lacks a
quorum
they're unable to perform that
regulatory function
the current board of court reporters has
two members
we lost a member unfortunately
due to retirement or resignation back in
august
and since that time they've had one
meeting
so
we are concerned about uh the ability to
to
make sure that their regulatory
functions are continuously performed
and that's why we're here today in
support of house bill 1182 happy to
answer any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
are there any questions from the
committee
representative schuett thank you madam
chair just one um
is the membership called for in this
board the same as the current membership
i believe the same the membership is
there's a decrease in the number of
individuals required our current
advisory boards are comprised of three
individuals and typically a licensing
board at least has five
and further questions follow-up do you
um do you have someone that you're
looking at to fill the vacancy
not at the moment our understanding is
that if this board were to be converted
all individuals would have to seek
appointment under the new under the new
model
thank you
alexander fellows
so i'm looking at the current statute
and it says that there are five members
so three are court reporters
the other two are a lawyer and a public
member oh yeah public
so
question representative fellows
um i i do have a question can you tell
me what the uh qualifications are
for a court reporter
do they have to take any kind of a test
so i i do believe there is an
examination um
but i'm not intimately familiar with
their requirements
um which are established in rural as you
know
actually they're in statute director
linda there's
310 a 169
requires a registered professional
reporter from the national court
reporters association or a certified
voice reporter from the national
verbatim reporters association so
there's two professional organizations
that they could be certified by
correct and then there's always the
requirements set forth and enrolls
you're you're correct representative
mcguire
okay
representative goalie
thank you madam chair i just want to go
back to the makeup of the board and how
this is going to be done from five
members to three members
and the time frame that's allowed
because
we're hearing
part of the problem is
getting these people
moved through governor and council
and
if that is part of the issue and we're
starting over with new members and are
starting to set up a new board
uh
looking at what the time frame is going
to be for this to be set up
i think representative goalie we might
want to
put in a transition clause that says the
existing court the court reporters on
the existing board are
transferred to the advisory board to
serve out their terms
because there's the same number of court
reporters but how many court reporters
are actually serving on the board so
there's two court reporters and there's
two members of the board at the moment
there's only 70
license court reporters in the state
right now
oplc would certainly support an
amendment that would include such
transition language
our our we don't have any currently
outstanding applications
for court reporters to sit on the board
and my experience has been
that generally if people can get us all
of their information on time
we provide it to the governor's office
as soon as we have all of the
outstanding requirements
other questions
jet reference
thank you
um
miss lindsay so in this case it's not a
matter of
the board necessarily meeting
it's an issue of the number of members
on the board is that correct
i think it's a combination of both so we
only have two members on the board so
that doesn't leave any wiggle room for
somebody to not be able to attend for
whatever reason
we need both of them to physically
appear in order to
conduct business
so obviously we are concerned about the
ability to maintain a quorum um
with with with those numbers
thank you
representative
thank you do you know do you know if
there are any um off the top of your
head requirements for how often this
board has to meet and do they receive
mileage
all boards receive mileage i do not know
off the top of my head if there's a
statutory requirement that they meet a
certain number of times per year
other questions
okay thank you for your time seeing
thank you very much
yes represent fellows as well to answer
my own question because now i've found
it it says that they
they must hold at least three regular
meetings per year
okay is there anyone else that who
wishes to testify on house bill 1182
obviously the court reporters don't mind
it
um
in that case i'm going to close the
public hearing on house bill 1182
and i think i will send this to
representative scitex committee for
transition language
and looking and examining other
language
good afternoon
1 45 we will open the
house hearing for
house bill
recognize representative schuett
thank you madam chair one
my apology i was just going to say that
good afternoon fellow committee members
for the record i'm representative shut i
represent merrimack 20 the towns of
pembroke and chichester
and as representative schmidt had stated
on the last bill
several
boards were requested by the oplc
to become advisory because of their
small size
and the difficulty in obtaining quorums
for meetings
so i undertook
the first one
to
do the board governing recreational
therapists and representative mcguire
who's listed as the co-sponsor
was originally going to do the
respiratory care practitioners
and she suggested that since the two
were so similar we combine them in one
so that's why you see both
professions and boards listed
in the one bill
i did go through carefully and as you
can probably see
a lot of the language includes
my favorite phrase
in consultation with the board
so that whenever
the executive director of oplc is
considering
educational qualification
adopting rules particular to the
profession and things of that sort
she will need to go back to at least one
member of the board
and so that they're aware of
whatever is being requested
other than that i think it's pretty
clear-cut um
and if you have any questions i will try
and answer them but as you know ms
courtney is here and she's probably
better qualified to answer any technical
questions
are there any questions for the
representative
thank you very much representative
stewart
ms robinson
good afternoon
my name is debbie robinson i am a
licensee of the recreational therapy
board license number zero zero two it
was a part of the original uh group that
was seeking licensure
for this profession
and what's in served on the original
board we are a small profession but in
need of this regulation so i am pleased
to see that there is an adaptation being
made to allow for quorum so that
activity can happen for the board
especially when there are instances of
folks that are moving into town
into the state that need to practice
also new graduates that need this
license to be able to practice their
profession and the lack of quorum lately
has delayed action so this is a way in
which the executive director can act in
order to
have those that are practicing be able
to do so
lawfully
and
more rapidly
thank you very much
representative schmidt
thank you ma'am chair
welcome ms robinson so is it your
understanding that under the new
arrangement
um
the
practice of your profession will not be
decided by the executive director but
rather in consultation with you
with regard to how to
modernize update or whatever it may be
your profession
given national standards changes or
whatever
um and that you will be the the the
source of
that that information
which the executive director will be
implementing
uh in association with you thank you for
the question i don't currently serve on
the board but i have spoken to one of
the board members in because they don't
work locally and i was able to come to
testify um and they are very much in
favor of this i also spoke to the
national office for our profession who
feels confident that this
legislation only changes that the board
would be advisory to the executive
director so that they would still
give have
very good input related to our field and
practice
but the activities of the board could
still happen
in consultation with the executive
director who i know and have full faith
in
thank you you're welcome
representative bailey
uh i must be the only one in the room
that doesn't know could you tell me what
a recreational therapist i'd be thrilled
to thank you for asking we are an allied
health profession sister sister
professions to occupational therapy
physical therapy speech therapy we're
often found in va centers we work in
nursing homes with hospice we work i
work in mental health i have for my
whole career
we also work in outpatient and inpatient
physical rehabilitation so just as an
occupational or physical therapist would
teach you to to do the motor and fine
motor and skills that you need to be
able to regain your life
the recreational therapist would look at
your passions and your enjoyments and
how you can regain those pieces of
yourself that are less
that are less
the things that people don't necessarily
think of that need to be rehabilitated
but yet if i told you you couldn't do
the top three things that you enjoyed
most in the world without adaptation and
that they were gone to you as a result
of your disability or injury your life
would be less and so we would look at
how do we make adaptations how do we get
a skier back on a mono ski or a sit ski
so that they can have that still passion
in their life even after an injury or
illness
thank you you're welcome thank you for
asking
representative goalie did you have a
question no are there any other
we can make that happen for you
thank you very much miss robinson thank
you
director courtney
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee lindsay courtney executive
director oplc
oplc is here in support of house bill
1446 which seeks to convert
the recreational therapy governing board
and the respiratory care practitioner
governing board to advisory boards
both of these boards have had
significant issues with quorum
the recreational therapy governing board
has not met since february of 2021
and the respiratory care practitioner
governing board has not met since march
of 2021
and so as of right now plc is issuing
licenses after 60 days by operation of
law
again without regard to whether or not
they are actually qualified to do so
so we have some concerns
particularly as it relates to issuing
licenses promptly into individuals who
qualify
but as well as to our
inability at present to modify rules as
well as conduct disciplinary hearings
if if it's so necessary
this bill would allow the office to
effectively communicate with advisory
board members
and conduct the board's business
and alleviate some of the quorum
problems that we've been having
so we urge your support of house bill
1446 and with that i'm happy to answer
any questions
representative o'brien yes this was a
solid hand compared to representative
googly is this
director uh we heard on the other bill i
don't see it but would there be a need
any transitional amendment or anything
else like that or this one's pretty
solid stand alone
i think we could certainly add the trend
transition
transitioning language to ensure that
those who are currently on the board
would be appointed on the new board
um we could certainly do that
some of the board members are
i would say for respiratory care we have
two in holdover
of the three that are appointed so it's
possible that they don't even want to
continue that they haven't sought
reappointment or they're not eligible
for reappointment and they've just
continued on
so that would be one thing that i think
we would need to consider
i think we can manage that thank you
representative schmidt
thank you man i'm sure
so let me ask you the converse of the
question that i asked ms robinson a
moment ago
um is it
my
my understanding correctly that it's not
your intention in under this new system
to be taking over
uh any this profession or any profession
but rather to facilitate a better
interaction of stakeholders and
administrators in terms of
of um
expediting
matters such as the quorum situation
you're wrestling with at the moment with
this board
but also
to
take away
administrative things that
um are
more of annoyance to board members
and
and time consuming in areas where they
frequently don't have any expertise but
in issues of substance about the
profession that's where their advice
would be
that your guide star
uh is that my understanding correct
yes thank you for the question
representative
ovlc fully believes that licensed
professionals need to
need to provide
need to be part of the decision-making
process as to how that profession should
be regulated
it's you know because those are the
individuals who are
best qualified to determine how to how
to adequately protect the public from
those um who may not be competent to
participate in that profession
so when we look at occupational
licensing
there's there's the regulation of
individuals in their practice and then
there's the administrative functions of
that practice
and what we've found obviously is that
the office
we're not experts in any particular
field we're not physicians we're not
recreational therapists um but we do
strive and we're getting better to be
experts in administrative law and
administrative procedures in compliance
with state statute and rules
and the individuals on the boards are
experts in their field and so we think
that we have to essentially marry the
two together in order to really have a
harmonious relationship and ensure that
we are regulating individuals in that
profession in a way that protects the
public as well as ensure compliance with
statutes and rules and i think that this
model accomplishes that we can leverage
the expertise of the individual board
members without
requiring them to get bogged down in in
the administrative process of
necessarily having to come in all the
time
and go through
you know menial tasks you know sitting
around and
choosing to for example
review every part of a continuing
education if that's if that's not what
they like to do
this particular field
particularly with respiratory care with
kova 19 we've seen
we've seen some significant issues and
challenges in in terms of our board
members being able to actually
participate
on these boards they're just needed at
their at their places of employment um
and so this would allow them to provide
that consultation that feedback
and allow us to effectively ensure that
a government is functioning while at the
same time leveraging their expertise
follow-up
thank you
so you're going on the record with
regard to how you intend to
administer
this particular
uh board and other boards uh under your
the new system um
but there there will come a time perhaps
in 20 or 30 years down the road that
when
you may no longer be the executive
director
and
so do you feel that this format is
sufficiently
straightforward that even an another
executive director one perhaps without
your
intention uh could could be more uh you
know the the czar of the the border
boards um and and
because i know that's one of the things
that
some of the practitioners have talked
with me about their concern
uh what about the future when you're no
longer the executive director
thank you yeah i think government always
has to have contingency plans we have to
be able to function and for these
particular boards they're not
functioning at the moment so there's
really no regulation happening no no
nothing going on with respect to these
two fields which i think is very
concerning
at the same time you need to have checks
and balances you need to make sure that
that those with expertise are part of
the solution
we've seen this model work here in new
hampshire
we currently have four advisory boards
it works well
with respect to body artists
and massage therapists
you know we seek their expertise their
input
and then we ensure that we implement
the rules and regulations and that i
really think is the checks and balance
of any
governmental regulation is really the
rule making process
you know we'd have to go through jail
card there would be opportunity for
public comment certainly if members of
the profession did not agree with
any of the rules that we would be
proposing we we are certain that um
that that you would hear about it
thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here today testifying and taking
questions
i want to go back to
[Music]
boards that are having trouble meeting
or aren't meeting currently
being an issue
have you
received any explanation as to why
they're not meeting is it because of
covid because of quorums because
positions aren't filled or all of the
above
um because i i just have a concern if i
go to advisory for everything instead of
addressing the real issue of why we're
not having a quorum
um
is my concern i mean is there a way to
solve the quorum problem
so what i can tell you is that we've
been
proactive in seeking
applications for qualified people to
serve on the boards we've done email
blasts i've engaged with a lot of the
associations that you know we work with
and have good relationships with to find
qualified people
i am not aware of a consistent issue
with
applications being held
and not put forth
i what i we have observed is that
certainly covid has impacted uh board
members both from being uncomfortable
with attending and physical uh and
physical presence as well as the fact
that we regulate you know the health
care professions so uh there's a
workforce shortage
um we've heard from board members that
they're having difficulties getting you
know time off from work to be able to
come
and then i think for those that are just
burned out you know this this may not be
something that um that they could devote
their time to so i think it's
it's personal to a lot of the
individuals who have been serving on the
boards
i think one thing you know the state
could look at is the number of positions
we have on boards
i think a lot of our boards are fairly
large
and maybe not
what they need to be
and that's something that i think we
could certainly consider
but i also think that
this could certainly resolve part of the
problem but i think you know there could
be other solutions out there to your
point representative
follow-up
then just one follow-up is
there
also not a bill
in the senate that might address
online or
being able to remote access and have
board meetings
yes there is a bill sponsored by senator
khan i think it was
the committee edna voted ought to pass
on consent
i forget the bill number
but i'm sure that will be making its way
over here that would permit the
licensing boards to operate remotely
follow-up representative goalie and
might that help in addressing the issue
especially when we have small boards of
three members that may be from all
corners of the state trying to meet here
in concord instead of at an easier
location
i think that could address it i'm not
sure that it would resolve the issue
with wreck therapy or with respiratory
care i'd have to take that back and look
at it i know respiratory care has three
members two are in holdover
and
so i don't know if that would resolve
the issues on these particular boards
but i think
by and large that would help
certainly with some of our boards in
quorum issues
certainly thank you
representative fellows
thank you
um
so
most board members regular board members
are appointed by
nominated by the governor and approved
by the executive council for these
advisory boards are the people going to
apply to you for these positions and are
you already doing that with some of the
board's advisory boards
yes so we just uh modeled this after the
existing advisory boards in which
the agency makes the appointments
um presently all positions with the
exception of i think guardian ad litem
that's just nominated by the governor
appointed by the governor the majority
of oplc boards are
gnc
appointments
i'm not sure that i understood so for
the advisory board are the advisory
boards different
and is the distinction that for advisory
boards that that you will appoint them
and for the regular
boards it goes through g and c
is that correct yep that's correct
that's the existing model so we would
just utilize this model that model thank
you
are there any for representative scitec
how many recreational therapists are
there
there are i thought i might be asked
this question so i wrote it down um 76
licensed recreational therapists
670 licensed respiratory care
practitioners as of the close of last
fiscal year
i'm following up on representative
o'brien it wasn't clear to me
is
uh transitional language advisable here
or not
you you described the the board was a
little shaky holdovers and that sort of
thing but
do you need a completely new board or
are you going to transition
i i don't think we need a completely new
board
the one concern i had with this bill is
that it takes effect 60 days after
passage and right now
particularly for respiratory care
because we tend to get those up more of
those applications
we are not able to do anything with
those applications for 60 days
so
i would i would
i would be inclined to recommend that
this if this bill were to pass that it
be effective immediately so that we can
at least start to get these applications
out the door
um and license these people
because particularly for respiratory
care we're contacted by facilities uh
residential care facilities long-term
care facilities that are just in need of
respiratory care practitioners because
they go over it and we can't license
them in a timely fashion
follow-up
that's fine for uh getting your licenses
out the door
the question that i have is if you feel
transitional language is
advisable for these
uh you may be aware that i've already
put one in your in basket if you
wouldn't mind putting a couple more and
that would be great absolutely i can do
that representative
are there any further questions for the
director
thank you very much thank you for your
time
are there any members of the public
that would like to testify for house
bill 1446
close to public hearing thank you
thank you okay good afternoon
it having reached 2 15. i'm going to
open the hearing on house bill 1460 and
call representative ukela
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee
my name is
representative josh okella
representing fremont danville and
brentwood
i am here today to introduce hb
uh 1416
about
removing the 1460 yep thank you
relative to
removing the age requirements from
the
occupational licenses statute
and
i
wanted to bring this to your
attention not
really to discuss uh you know the
some of the aid the weird age
requirements
like
occupational
therapists being able to be licensed at
17 but
the
massage therapists have to be 18 but a
temporary
massage therapist has to be 21
you know
those types of things i'm not going to
be focusing on today today i would like
to focus on just the idea that
the government shouldn't be
discriminating based on
on age
and if they meet if the people uh
meet all the other qualifications you
know schooling and
um
you know graduating having a specific
degree
in the field or whatever the other
requirements are in the rsa
that the age requirement shouldn't be a
barrier on it of its own
you know giving
getting a license doesn't necessarily
mean that you are able to get a job
there's still the
the
practice you know the the issue of
seeking employment and
if if they
plan to do the business themselves
they still have to you know convince
people that to hire them so the issue
really what we're discussing here is
whether or not in addition to all the
other requirements
that age should be one and age obviously
does not
reflect maturity it's just a just a
number
and so so so um
there's also
the issue of
um
you know
emancipation when we just passed a new
emancipation law not too long ago and
part of the
emancipation
statute says that
if a person is emancipated they have the
right
to obtain a license
to operate equipment or perform a
service
and so
obviously all these emancipated people
will be under 18
and so
there is a conflict also between
their right to be able to obtain a
license to perform the service
and
the statutes which may
not
allow for any exceptions for that for
their age
and so i'm happy to answer any questions
[Music]
thank you representative akela i'm i've
always been amused by the requirement
that someone have
a graduate degree in dentistry and b of
at least 18 years of age
so that's unlikely combination right
okay ruffin pearson and then o'brien
thank you madam chair one of the things
that is jumping off the page here with
me involves some of the professions
where humans touch other humans
like occupational therapists there's a
bunch of them so
where my concerns lie here is that if if
we're talking about removing minimum age
requirements
we're talking about the potential for
someone who's not a legal adult to
perform
some of these functions how does that
work if litigation is entered into
against someone who's not even a legal
adult that's performing a practice in
any one of these professions
thank you for the question um
i think that uh
the
[Music]
so
i think the ques the answer to that is
one
they could be
emancipated as i just suggested
and
those would
follow the normal course um there's also
the example that i already gave that uh
occupational therapists
are allowed to be licensed at 17.
and so
they're
they are touching someone
and and in my experience with
occupational licenses uh or occupational
uh therapists they are
you know expected to be well
versed in you know the muscles and how
to uh achieve a specific goal whereas
like massage therapists
um it's i think a little bit more about
general relaxation and stuff like that
for for you know definitely someone
that's you know at a at a spa or
something like that um but as i also
said that there's just because the
license
can be granted does not mean that they
could be hired right you would still
need to be hired by a specific place and
um you would also want to
uh or if they you know brought their own
practice they would still need to be
able to you know hold the business
license and all of those types of things
so
i think that it will be
as as it was suggested inside the fiscal
note this is um
very unlikely to increase the number of
occupational licenses in
new hampshire it would just be
a sign that we're not going to
discriminate
based on it
thank you for the question
representative ryan
thank you madam chip thank you
representative for taking
my question in my previous life before
joining the fine people here in edna i
was on transportation
and would you believe that we do have
a driver's license for people who are
not emancipated at that particular time
yet
by recommendation of many groups because
of the uh
the mind of a young person isn't
completely developed they have what's
called like a tear license
so there's certain hours of operation
that they have to go through uh there's
certain
there's people that they cannot have in
the front seat of the vehicle there's a
whole bunch of
rules that apply to the young driver for
their particular safety and to also too
would you believe that by motor vehicle
law emancipation does not start until
the age of 18.
thank you for the question
being on
children and family law as my committee
i would believe that i hear a lot of
arguments from
from
people arguing that uh people the age of
13 should be able to change their sex
and people the age of 16 should be able
to vote and people over the age of 21
or up to the age of 21 shouldn't be
punished for uh
for uh you know cr non-violent crimes
because their brain hasn't been formed
so i would believe that people choose
all different kinds of
evidence
to
support
the fact that certain ages should not or
should be
able to decide
and it it in my experience it's not
consistent
thank you madam chair okay
representative bailey
thank you
it's maybe really somewhat related but
can you be sued under age 18 or does it
fall on your parents
if you're emancipated or anyone let's
say you're not you just get one of these
licenses and you're not emancipated and
um you
your parents i believe yeah
so
isn't some follow-up i guess isn't that
a bit of a problem
does this make sense
i mean i like the concept but wouldn't
it have to be in
in conjunction with doing something
about that
thank you for the question
um
so as i as i suggested before there's i
don't believe that this is going to um
dramatically increase or
or maybe even increase at all the number
of people
that are licensed um
because of the other qualifications that
are necessary like graduating uh college
and
and um
those types of things
would limit the number of people that
would even
meet the other qualifications and so the
um
what you're suggesting i believe is not
that you know someone might be able to
get away with not doing any not having
any consequences
it just may not be the person
that
that if they were
let's say if they were not
18 and they
were a physical therapist now
um and they got hired and they hurt
someone
i think that we would be in the same
situation that we are that we could be
in right now
and that the parents would be held
liable and not not the minor
and so
um
i think that it's not that it would open
up the you know it to the wild wild west
and someone's still being held
accountable
so i would i would uh say that that
would be enough
thank you wouldn't the employer be more
likely to be liable
yes
yes the obviously the employer would be
you know if you if you hurt someone
while you're employed that employer is
going to be the one sued and not you
and a non-impasse and
emancipated minor would have a lot of
trouble setting up a business right so
yes
they would be an employee i would
imagine
right and so they were
you know it's possible that they would
be
um you know
able to get the license and maybe um
work
as a apprentice
under someone but it's very unlikely
that they're going to be
able to uh perform the job under the age
of 18 let's say but but that's not alway
not you know everything that we're
talking about also there is the require
you know there is
um
home inspectors can be 18 but the the
the engineer
that built that built it has to be 21
right and so we're we're not just
talking about
um people under the age of 18
and and the issues that that right rises
from that
thank you are there any other questions
from the committee representative fellow
thank you
it appears to me that that this is a
list of
all
the
places where
age is a requirement in licensing
not motor vehicle but in the under the
things that this committee hears about
and
if if that is true
i'm just wondered wonder specifically if
you gave any thought
to the massage therapist in that area
because this committee has heard
a lot about
control of massage parlors
and the
the in in in thinking of it from the
perspective of protecting
16 year olds from
being massage therapists
and the consequences should that happen
thank you for the question um
i
as a young person i do
um
i did
seek to
eliminate the
discrimination that i see in
occupational licenses so yes this this
uh
bill is focused on the
the occupational license requirement of
age and not of any other um
anything outside of that scope
and
i am obviously not on this committee and
so i'm not as aware of the
uh
the desire
to
ensure that people under the age of 18
are not
massage therapists
but
um i think that
if the people are you know qualified
to be a massage therapist then i don't
think that you should be discriminating
on that
against them for that
for their age
just like i wouldn't suggest that we
discriminate against people that are
older
representative
thank you um
you know i wouldn't you think that if
in something inappropriate is going to
go on in a massage therapist which i
assume is the concern
that that in and of itself would be
illegal uh separate from
the age of the person and
if the place is going to be operated
with illegal activity going on
i'm not you know would you expect that
they'd be careful about making sure
people were licensed whatever their age
thank you for the question um
i i believe that you know if a person is
not breaking any
law
in their massage then they should not be
forbidden from doing that massage and so
i do believe that if there was nefarious
actors
they can
if they're breaking one law they
i'm not sure that um breaking a second
law is is a is a significant barrier to
them
thank you
any further questions
okay thank you very much representative
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1460.
okay i seeing none i'll close the public
hearing
madam chair yes
if i may
have the committee's indulgence for just
a few moments
i'm grateful for the fact that
we can stream
hearings and executive sessions
when we are not present as the
committee's aware i was not able to be
here
last monday afternoon because i had a
doctor's appointment
but i happened to hear a comment during
the executive session on cacr 30
which
kind of
peaked my
memory
one of the members of this committee
stated that
during the 2016 election
there had been over 11 000
of
one day affidavits signed to enable
people to be able to vote
and that over 8 thousand of them did not
meet the legal requirements after the
fact
and that did not sit with what i
remembered from those i thought that
that was once where the attorney
general's or the secretary of state sent
a letter and these were not returned
well i checked with the secretary of
state excellent and you have enough you
have some correction for us yes i do
assuming that the
numbers that were quoted
were affected from the
um
the the totals that come to the 11 000
were for the
section of votes from june through
december which would be the state
primary and general elections
and according to a report that the
secretary of state's office
sent to the speaker of the house and the
president of the senate
the total number of votes that were
objected to and not
responded to properly was
uh spread those over the four elections
involved
and from what i was told by the
secretary of state's office there are
310 polling places in the state
the average would be very small for the
numbers that were not responded to
thank you for that information i don't
that may have been mentioned during the
executive session but i don't think it
influenced very many people's vote well
i will say that the the member did say
that he was taking the numbers off the
top of his head
but i brought it up only because i think
it should be corrected
if it was in the minutes i'm not sure
that kind of number is in the minutes
but if you will present that give that
data to our clerk he will do the
appropriate thing i certainly will thank
you okay
all right
madam chair i think
not that we're going to debate the last
election but where some of those numbers
came from is in the state of new
hampshire when you move here you have a
certain window in order to transfer your
license to the state of new hampshire
that number exceeded 5 000
people that registered to vote and
failed to have their license transferred
to the state of new hampshire within 90
days the reason the secretaries of state
office did not put that under the same
category is is because it did not jive
with law at the time as far as the
definition of residency but it did jive
under the dmv law so that's where some
of those numbers come from
and that's why they weren't pursued but
that number exceeded 5 000
so that's
unless i mean that's that's the number
that's what i'm what is most commonly
referenced is the definition lots of
issues and lots of numbers that and i i
think people remember different ones
depending on their their point of view
in any event uh i want to thank you all
for being here we are meeting monday on
the
for monday the 7th for our executive
session so far i don't know of anyone
who's not going to be here
represent goalie i trust you'll check
with representative font now
he will be here all right thank you it'd
be nice to see him again
representative schmidt that's okay
there we go um
there we we exact three bills yesterday
and needed four committee reports i only
have one
thank you representative sansa nestaso
the others are
not yet of in in those are the only open
ones and i'd appreciate getting them at
your earliest convenience
and
yeah
for your information this is the
package that's given to state employees
on the reta uh deferred compensation
plan it was asked for at the at the
hearing and
the director brought them by today
for your reading pleasure
okay anything and i think we're done for
today unless somebody has something
okay thank you
okay
in well
i have to keep track of stuff for the
democratic leader's office
um
well apparently um
yes
okay
oh
in there
very very curious
that created
yes
i
was laughing
well
i mean you know it's going to take a
couple years just to get some training
and yeah
as i said
you know there
but i mean literally i mean
go on youtube and see some of these
eight-year-olds playing